Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss!
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss!
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss!
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss!
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
Na gut, Videos Streaming mag mehr haben, aber bei ner Shopping Plattform, überleg mal wie
viele Sachen, bei ner Shopping Plattform dahinter laufen müssen, dass du auf 30TB die Minute
kommst.
Ja, ist echt so, da ist Ruby on Rails tatsächlich mit dafür verantwortlich, dass das Web so
ist, wie es heute ist, ja, das war das erste, ich nenne zwar so moderne Web Framework, so
das erste moderne Richtung, äh, wie heißt das, ähm, MVC, Model View Controller, was
eben so richtig, so richtig Hype und Mainstream hatte.
Damals bei Ruby on Rails haben die Leute ja noch nach Rockstar Developern gesucht, das
ist auch so eine ultra bescheuerte Bezeichnung.
Der Friseur sieht heute noch aus wie 25, ja wir haben Crytek, aber Crytek spielt sicherlich
nicht in derselben Liga wie SAP, und außerdem muss man sagen, Crytek hat ja leider die letzten
Jahre, es ist jetzt besser geworden mit Hunt Showdown, allerdings die Jahre dazwischen,
haben die ja auch nicht viel, wo man nennenswertes hinbekommen.
Ja gut, wir waren bei vielen Sachen mal ziemlich gut, ihr müsst euch mal das Foto, das Gruppenfoto
angucken, ähm, wo Albert Einstein den Nobelpreis bekommen hat, warte mal, Einstein Group Foto,
ja, Alter, da sind sehr viele Deutsche drauf und von den Namen her kennst du gefühlt heute
noch die Hälfte, also wir waren mal um diese Zeit richtig krass was wissenschaftliche Sachen
angeht, aber das mit Internet haben wir komplett verkackt, kennt jemand noch BTX, wurde damals
von der Telekom als der neue Shit angepriesen, weiß nicht ob das jemals, ob das jemals jemand
gesehen hat, BTX, sieht ein bisschen aus wie Videotext, das ähm, war aber über Modem,
oder ISDN damals, meint ihr wirklich, jetzt war eine Frage an euch Chat, hätte 2000 rum
jemand gesagt, analoges Telefon, überlebt ISDN, hätte man die Leute ausgelacht, damals
war ISDN der neueste Shit, ja heute denkt man sich, oh, zum Glück muss man kein ISDN
mehr supporten, ISDN kam zu spät, ISDN war eine super Idee für Telefon, aber ISDN kam
zu einer Zeit, oder wurde zu einer Zeit Mainstream, wo die Leute eigentlich schon aufs Internet
geschielt haben, oh ja, dann ist ja alles gut, es gibt heute noch sehr viele Fiveheads, allerdings
habe ich den Eindruck, viele von hinten sind ausgewandert, leider, oder haben keinen Bock,
das dachte der sich immer noch, na dann muss er aber ganz schön, das war ja abzusehen,
Moin, Serious Max, Leute, ich muss noch ein bisschen an meinem Bonbon glutschen, dass
mein Hals wieder besser wird, lasst euch nicht stören, sagt mir Bescheid, wenn es zu nervig
ist, ja, ich sacke sozusagen gerade, ach ja, Chat, muss euch ja noch was zeigen, es hat
heute unter dem Video bei mir, habe ich das irgendwo auf, unter dem Video bei mir hat
mich jemand gefragt, was ich zu der Stellenanzeige von ihm, von dort, wo er die Webseiten betreut
von dem Unternehmen, was ich dazu sage, und da habe ich ihm gesagt, ja schickt mir das
doch einfach mal den Link per Twitter, und das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an, offene Stellen,
warte mal, wenn ich das mit dem Darkreader aufhabe, sieht es dann an, okay, das ist schon
mal eine gute Webseite, die auch ohne Darkreader ordentlich aussieht, da bin ich schon mal,
das ist schon mal Pluspunkt, Pluspunkt, also was haben wir hier zur Auswahl, die Seite
finde ich schon mal ganz schick, wir haben zur Auswahl Frontendentwickler, Backendentwickler,
oder Azubi, können wir auch mal aufmachen, gucken wir mal, Frontendentwickler, gucken
wir uns mal an, also, und ich habe ihm auf Twitter geschrieben, ich zeige das heute mal
im Stream, und mein Stream kann da sein Senf zu abgeben, also, sollte hier oben nicht ein
Name von der Firma stehen, also es sind die Business Unicorns, das sind Stockbilder, oder,
die kommen ja äußerst bekannt vor, ist das nicht, sind die Fotos nicht so ein super weit
verbreiteter Image Satz, ach, die hast du selbst gemacht, okay, dann sieht es einfach
nur vom Style so aus, was jetzt aber für die Stellenanzeige nicht wirklich relevant
ist, ja, okay, also, kriegt man Zeug über die Firma erzählen, so, der Job, es geht hier
um Frontendentwickler, Umsetzung komplexer Kundenanforderung, Entwicklung von unkonventionellen
Lösungen, ich finde, also, meine persönliche Meinung, das ist vielleicht busy wenig, das
kannst du ja zu mehr oder weniger jedem Job sagen, als Erkenntnis hat der MLC als erst
modernes, modernes JavaScript würde ich tatsächlich hinschreiben, du hast sicherlich noch welche,
die kommen da mit jQuery um die Ecke, oder sowas, das finde ich gut, das finde ich gut,
bei modernem Web-Framework würde ich vielleicht noch irgendwie was hinschreiben, was zum
Beispiel, also, im Prinzip das, was ihr verwendet, wäre schon mal ganz gut, wenn die Leute das
können, Technik Verständnis von Jitscheln, gutes Deutsch, Englisch, also, es geht jetzt
darum, Chat, ob ihr euch angesprochen fühlen würdet oder nicht, eigenverantwortliches
Arbeiten und Mitdenken, okay, und das sind die Benefits, ich finde es insgesamt ein bisschen
kurz, also, ich denke, man könnte da durchaus mehr schreiben, wenn ihr Benefits habt, also,
wenn ihr sowas habt, wie zum Beispiel, ich habe ja schon auf Twitter geschrieben, wenn
ihr sowas habt, wie höhenverstellbare Schreibtische oder freie Betriebssystem-Auswahl, ich persönlich
finde freie Betriebssystem-Auswahl immer ein super Punkt, wenn es das gibt, wenn man
das reinschreibt, also, für mich ist das ein unglaublicher Pluspunkt, freie Betriebssystem-Auswahl,
steht da doch, oh, ach da, ach ja, ups, das stand da schon die ganze Zeit da, ich habe
das nicht gesehen, als ich vorhin reingeguckt habe, Hardware und Dienstfahrrad Leasing über
Entgeltumwandlung, also, ich finde es intern ist viel Gutmanagement, na doch, ist schon
lesbar, ich habe aber nicht richtig geguckt, also, wie gesagt, ich finde es nicht schlecht,
aber ich hätte also keine Schmerzen, wenn da noch ein bisschen genauer stehen würde,
was denn so auf einen zukommt, weil das ist doch schon sehr allgemein, ich weiß nicht,
chat, was sagt ihr, inwieweit würdet ihr euch angesprochen fühlen, was würdet ihr
noch gerne haben wollen, guck mal mal, Backend, benötigte Qualifikation, ja, das fände ich
auch nicht schlecht, wenn das drin steht, Umsetzung, Arbeiten mit Apis, Entwicklung von unkonventionellen
Lösungen, gut, das ist auch mehr oder weniger für alles, das finde ich gut, das finde ich
gut, dass das drin steht, Shit plus Docker Erfahrung, ja, auch nicht verkehrt, Linux
Erfahrung, ja, das ist schon ein bisschen konkreter, ja, welches JavaScript Framework
würde ich auch reinschreiben, oder zumindest, was einem am liebsten ist, sieht nach Consulting
aus, ja gut, wenn das Consulting Zeug ist, also sprich, wir verschachern, wir verschachern
Leute an andere Unternehmen, dann ist das natürlich was anderes, ja, aber ist es glaube
ich nicht, oder, weiß ich nicht, was machen die denn, keine Ahnung, Web of Tomorrow, Case
Studies, ne, die entwickeln, die entwickeln Web Anwendungen, oder, Entwicklung, steht
doch hier, ach so, Beratung, ja, im Prinzip, du kannst da deinen Shop oder sowas entwickeln
lassen, ja, ich bin da immer, ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich bin da immer sehr unkreativ, was
sowas angeht, also, ich könnte sowas auch nicht schreiben, bin da immer relativ planlos,
ich weiß nur, dass ich auf der Arbeit bei uns mal bei einer Stellenanzeige einen riesig
langen Text an den jeweiligen Teamleiter geschrieben hab, warum ich das überhaupt nicht ansprechend
finde und bis heute hat sich nachher nichts geändert und die wundern sich immer noch,
warum sie nichts finden, ich sag nicht, dass automatisch mit meiner Änderung die Leute
Schlange stehen würden oder sowas, aber sicherlich noch mehr und da waren halt so Sachen drinne
wie, wir sollten ja vorheben, dass wir eine Kantine haben, wir sollten ja vorheben, dass
wir eine freie Betriebssystem-Auswahl haben, wir sollten ja vorheben, dass wir höhenverstellbare
Schreibtische haben, wir sollten ja vorheben, dass wir ein Dienst-Handy bekommen, ich weiß
nicht, wie es bei euch mit flexibler Arbeitszeit aussieht, also Chat, wenn ihr noch irgendwas
hinzuzufügen habt, schreibt es in den Chat, werden sich wahrscheinlich freuen, so, was
gucken wir uns denn jetzt an, oh, Moment, ich muss mal kurz in den Chat gucken, ich
kann euch jetzt nicht zeigen, weil da müsste ich mich liegen, wo ich arbeite, das war mit
die Schlechteste Stellenanzeige, die man sich vorstellen kann, auf der anderen Seite stand
bei uns total fies Schwachsinn drinne, so nach dem Motto, du sollst VC, Sus dolor, du sollst
Active Directory, windows können, so komplette sinnlose Dinge, die du eigentlich gar nicht
Brauchst du den Support?
Es ging ja um eine Support-Position auch noch.
Meinung zu Bifron, was ist das denn?
Secure your world, protect your game from cheating and hacking.
Ah, bestimmt AI-gestützte Anti-Cheat oder sowas, Blockchain, Blockchain AI Anti-Cheat.
Stonks, Anti-Virtual-Maschinen und Anti-Debugging-Features.
Okay, da kann ich nichts zu sagen, da habe ich zu wenig Plan von, um mich da qualifiziert
zu äußern.
Was, da sind die ehemaligen Entwickler von EAC und Vanguard?
Okay.
Taugt das?
Keine Ahnung.
Hm, okay.
Hallo Mugs, sorry, hallo Wubblers, ich bin fast mit dem Master fertig und im Master codet
man nicht mehr wirklich viel.
In den Stellenanzeigen steht aber immer gute Kenntnisse Java oder das schreckt mich immer
etwas ab.
Na ja, wie gut würdest du denn deine Kenntnisse in Java einschätzen?
Ich meine, nur weil man nicht mal tagtäglich größere Sachen programmiert, kann man ja
trotzdem so weit den Durchblick haben, um wieder schnell reinzukommen.
Und mal davon abgesehen, man kann ja auch ohne Probleme so ein paar Übungsprojekte machen
daheim.
Also wenn du jetzt nicht so komplett planlos bist und da mal schon ganz gut drinnen warst,
finde ich, spricht da eigentlich nichts dagegen.
Ich meine, solange du dich jetzt nicht irgendwie grad als Senior Big Brain Lead Developer was
auch immer bewirbst und dann sagst, ja ich hab vor zwei Jahren zum letzten Mal drei Zeilen
Hello World Java programmiert, dann ist das eigentlich kein Problem.
Würde ich so sehen, ob die Personalabteilung das auch so sieht, sei mal dahingestellt.
Was, ich freu mir gar nicht so viele VMs.
Die VM, die ich mit Abstand am häufigsten benutze, ist meine Deluxe VM.
Da immer einschalten.
Und bei der Gelegenheit verliere ich das, ich mach die Qt VM auch mal ab.
Auch mal an.
Hast du gesehen, dass Inscope Funnel wird, ja hab ich vorhin gelesen.
Dann warum nicht, der ist auch bald irgendwann mal 30, nicht mehr allzu langer Zeit glaub
ich.
Wir wissen ja jetzt, der müsste auch so 28, 29, bald 30 oder so sein.
27, ja ist doch ganz normales Alter.
So Chat, einmal für euch, bevor wir wieder ausmachen.
Ok, wir machen wieder aus.
Ja, also ich benutze die Deluxe VM eigentlich fast täglich mehrere Stunden.
Inscope hat genug Kohleunterhalt zu bezahlen.
Ja, warst mir keine Gedanken.
So ein Desktop, wenn der Chef vorbeikommt, wieso ist das Problem?
Das sieht wenigstens aus, als würde man was arbeiten.
Außer Chat, ihr kennt das doch, sagt mir eine Sache und ich sag euch wo sie ist auf dem
Desktop.
Ist doch total easy.
Nur die Noobs haben irgendwelche Ordner und sortieren das dann irgendwohin oder sowas.
Das ist doch, so muss das sein.
Nein, da ist schon ein bisschen viel Schwachsinn drauf, ja irgendwie so ein komisches Video,
was wir mal zur Bewegungserkennung gebraucht haben, so braucht keiner mehr.
Server 2, Server 2 gibt es glaube ich nicht.
Ach doch, da oben Server 2.
Sowas nennt er Server, guckt euch das mal an.
Irgend so ein billiges Case, komplett auseinander gefrickelt.
Massive Server.
Wo ist der Poggers, ich weiß gar nicht ob der auf dem Desktop überhaupt ist, ob der
ist gar nicht auf dem Software, ach doch hier unten da.
So ich hab alles schnell gefunden, also ich blick da durch, außerdem, irgendwo muss
der Kram doch hin.
Und warum sollte man den Desktop anders betrachten als jeden x-beliebigen anderen Ordner oder
habt ihr in jedem Ordner Unterordner und Unterordner und Unterordner, warum sollte der Desktop
eine Sonderstellung haben bei Ordnern im Vergleich zu den normalen anderen Ordnern?
Genau, warum sollte man den Desktop als Desktop verwenden?
Wozu?
Was ist denn das hier, kann ich das anklicken?
Ah, das ist die Firmware für das Thermometer, da weiß ich wieder, da war letzten Daten was
mit IT Leitung, ne, das ist die Stellenanzeige, die wir heute im Video angeguckt haben.
Wieso hat man zweimal Firefox auf dem Desktop und LibreOffice?
Hat man auf dem Desktop, weil Firefox der Meinung ist, beim Updaten sich zweimal da
platzieren zu müssen.
So und LibreOffice hat man hier, weil das ein Link ist, der beim installieren schlicht
und ergreifend angelegt wurde.
Und nachdem ich auf meinem Desktop nichts mache, wie normale Leute auf ihrem Desktop, ist
es ein ganz normaler Ordner und es juckt mich nicht.
Der gehts gut, die Licht gerade auf dem Schrank drüben glaube ich.
Ist bei deinem Arbeits-PC auch so auf dem Desktop?
Weißt du wie der Desktop von meinem Arbeits-PC aussieht?
So, genau so, mein Arbeits-PC hat nämlich keinen Desktop, wo man Icons drauf machen
kann.
Hier läuft ein Browser, hier läuft ein Terminal und hier läuft meistens irgendein Editor,
das heißt ich hab gar keinen Desktop, also gar keinen Anwendungszweck für Desktops,
weil ich Anwendung eigentlich nur im Fullscreen hab.
Ah, das ist eine gute Frage.
Ja, sie wollten mich auf der Arbeit zu Windows zwingen, aber nachdem mir noch keiner erklären
konnte, wie ich dann gescheit arbeiten soll, geschweige denn mir überhaupt ein Windows
NotePick zur Verfügung stellen, dass man vielleicht sich das mal angucken kann, fällt
das wohl auf kurze Sicht erstmal flach.
Ich hab die meisten Sachen bei mir in Linux, entweder Repo, Downloads oder tatsächlich
direkt im Home liegen, ja warum auch nicht, ne, ja das ist der Wahnsinn bei uns.
Das ist eine gute Frage, dazu brauchen wir erstmal was, was wir basteln können.
Ich wollt mir ja Discord Selfhouse zur Discord Alternativen demnächst angucken.
Da gibt's ja ein paar, die wahrscheinlich alle nicht mal ansatzweise so gut sind wie
das Original.
Die ist auch im Schrank, die Katze ist auch im Schrank, im Schlafzimmer wahrscheinlich.
Achja stimmt, ich hab Anfang des Monats ja gesagt, ich mach Weihnachtsmodes rein.
Ich glaube das lohnt sich jetzt auch nicht mehr Weihnachtsmodes zu machen, oder?
Chat was meint ihr, lohnt sich noch Weihnachtsmodes, doch, wenn ich das jetzt reinmache, ist es
bis Ostern immer noch drinne, ihr wisst genau ich hab das das letzte Mal bis keine Ahnung
im Juni oder so drinne gehabt die Weihnachtsmodes, wenn ich die jetzt reinmache werden wir sie
nicht mehr los, das ist egal, dann nächstes Jahr schreien die Leute wieder, Max ich will
endlich wieder normales Kekwe haben, übrigens heute ne, unter dem Video was ich heute hoch
geladen hab, das da, da waren ja einige Leute ein wenig getriggert, weil ich mich über
die christliche Stellenanzeige lustig gemacht hab, weiß gar nicht warum die Leute bei so
kleinen Sachen immer direkt vom Glauben abfallen, da muss man doch mal durch, oder, da kann
man doch mal Augen zu und durch, ich mein klar man muss sich nicht drüber freuen, aber
ich kann mir doch auch nicht alles zu Herzen nehmen, weil eigentlich mal, Moment, die Beschreibung
von meinem Video ist weg, ich glaube aber nicht, dass die wirklich, ich glaube nicht
dass die irgendjemand gelöscht hat, sondern dass das YouTube nicht richtig gespeichert
hat, das Video hatte eigentlich noch eine Beschreibung in der ersten Zeile, da stand
sinngemäß sowas wie, es wurde mal wieder Zeit für, was hab ich geschrieben, es wurde
mal wieder Zeit für Stellenanzeigen und diesmal mit besonders weihnachtlichen, keine Ahnung
mit, was hab ich geschrieben, mit besonders weihnachtlichen, weihnachtlichen Touch oder
sowas, aber ist es Swag, okay, ich glaube aber YouTube hat es nicht richtig gespeichert,
das buggt einfach mal, das buggt öfters mal rum, was ziemlich bescheuert ist, was mich
gewundert hat in dem Video, es gibt tatsächlich Leute, die sagen, dass man Scrum Master und
Projektleiter in einem sein kann, ich weiß nicht, wie das gehen soll, Gottes Zorn, genau,
das stimmt, ja, aber manche, manche waren, weil es cringe ist, manche waren tatsächlich
ein bisschen getriggert und ich verstehe, ich verstehe schon, warum man so, wenn man super
gläubig ist, kann man sich da drüber aufregen, aber das ist doch eigentlich die Luft nicht
wert, im Endeffekt.
Am besten fand ich den, der mir erzählen wollte, dass sich Glauben und Wissenschaft
nicht ausschließen, vor allem, wo ich vor Naturwissenschaften gesprochen hab und das
stelle ich mir wirklich schwer vor, also ich stelle es mir wirklich schwer vor, gerade
im Bereich, sagen wir mal irgendwie, ja im naturwissenschaftlichen Bereich zu sein und
das zu wissen, was man eben heutzutage über unsere, unser Weltbild so weiß und dann gleichermaßen
gläubig zu sein, das stelle ich mir sehr schwierig vor, weil dann musst du ja quasi
an Dinge glauben, von denen du weißt, dass sie mit an Sicherheit grenzender Wahrscheinlichkeit
nicht so sind, d.h. du musst dann eine Sache von beiden ausblenden, blende ich das eigentliche
aus, von dem ich normalerweise überzeugt sein müsste, dass es richtig ist oder blende
ich das aus, was ich glauben müsste, das ist einfach ein nicht überwindbarer Konflikt,
der da entsteht und ich weiß nicht, wie das zusammen funktionieren soll, das kann ich
mir, kann ich mir nicht erklären, wie das, wie das gehen soll, es gibt Leute, die biegen
sich das immer zurecht, ist ja auch vollkommen in Ordnung, ich habe da überhaupt keine Schmerzen
mit, die sollen alle glauben und machen, was sie wollen, aber ich verstehe halt nicht,
wie man das unter einen Hut bringen möchte, hast du smarte Lampen bei dir im Haus eingebaut?
Ja, ich habe einige, ich habe jetzt, wenn der Weihnachtsbaum an ist, habe ich, warte mal,
1, 2, 3, 4 LED-Streifen mit Controller und 1, 2, 3 RGB-Lampen und noch ein paar auf Reserve,
ja habe ich, was willst, willst du wissen, ja dann ist ja das nächste Problem, wo fängt
es an und wo hört es auf, also wenn du anfängst die Sachen nicht mehr mördlich zu nehmen,
die da drin stehen, dann hast du glaube ich am Ende noch mehr Probleme, als du vorher
eh schon hattest beim erklären, also ich finde das funktioniert bloß noch, wenn man komplett
die aktuellen Erkenntnisse oder das aktuelle Weltbild einfach ausblendet, aber wie gesagt,
es soll ja jeder glauben, was er will, das ist ja jedem sein gutes Recht, aber ich verstehe
halt nicht, wie man es unter einen Hut bringen kann, ja das frage ich mich, wie das so jemand
hinkriegt.
Sag mal, zumindest Informatik ist jetzt nicht zwangsläufig was in der Richtung, wo ich
sagen würde, es schließt sich prinzipiell aus, aber der interessiert sich ja dann sicherlich
auch ein bisschen für, von Mathe bis Physik und spätestens da ist es halt mit, wie soll
ich sagen, an Sicherheit grenzender Wahrscheinlichkeit so, dass zum Beispiel die Welt nicht in sieben
Tagen erschaffen wurde und ich weiß nicht, wie man das unter einen Hut bringen will,
das auf der einen Seite zu wissen und das dann aber nicht glauben zu können, weil es
nicht zueinander passt, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, wie die Leute das unter einen
Hut kriegen.
Ich glaube, ganz ehrlich, jetzt habe ich das Wort verwendet, das realistischste, was
wir in dieser Richtung gesehen haben, also das, nein nicht realistischste, aber das vielleicht
noch am wahrscheinlichste ist das was, ist das Scientology oder wer ist das mit den Aliens,
die uns irgendwann abholen, das ist ja von allen diesen Sachen noch in irgendeiner Art
und Weise das logischste und das sagt schon was, wenn irgendwelche abgedrehten durchgeknallten
Insekten noch die beste Erklärung haben, dann sollte man sich vor Gedanken drüber machen.
Wer ist denn das mit dem, dass die Aliens einen abholen, ich glaube, das ist nicht Scientology,
irgendeiner glaubt, dass quasi, wenn die Welt untergeht, uns die Aliens im Raumschiff abholen
und ich glaube, das sind die Zeugen Jehovas, die mit dem Alien Raumschiff, oder?
Ich frage mich eh, wie die bestimmen wollen, wer denn da jetzt reinkommt und wer nicht
und naja, egal, zumindest, das ist ja noch die wahrscheinlichste Variante von alledem,
es ist ja durchaus, also im Bereich des Möglichen, dass hier vielleicht irgendwann mal Außerirdische
zu landen, die Chancen sind nicht sonderlich groß, aber wahrscheinlich größer, als das
die Welt in sieben Tagen erschaffen würde.
Sind das geflashte Lampen oder welche sind das?
Nein, das sind keine geflashten Lampen, das sind Liveaxe hab ich, Liveaxe RGB Lampen und
die LED Streifen sind mit ESP32 Microcontroller, ja die sind geflasht mit WLED, aber ich hab
zum größten Teil so Dinge, Alter was ist mit euch los, normalerweise kostet 40 Euro
oder so, sind die noch, sind die noch bei Sin, ja so, das sind die normalen Preise irgendwie
dafür, toll, ich glaube es geht los, ja ich finde die Liveaxe Dinger ganz okay, die sind
allerdings schön hell, nein Philips Hue Lampen hab ich nicht, das halte ich für ein ziemlich
teures und zu abgeschottetes Ökosystem und ja ich weiß, man kann die Dinger mittlerweile
integrieren, aber es kommt öfters mal vor, dass Philips Hue, also jeder berühmt sich
dafür mit Firmware Updates irgendwelche Funktionen abschaltet und sowas, das muss nicht sein,
sicherlich ist das alles nur eine Interpretationsfrage, das Problem ist nur, wenn man anfängt davon
abzuweichen, was da steht, also wenn man sagt, hey das was in der Bibel steht oder was in
irgendwelchen heiligen Schriften steht, wenn man davon abweicht und sagt, ah das darf
man nicht so wortwörtlich nehmen, dann ist die erste Frage, die sich einem auftränkt
ist, warum lügen einen die Schreiber an, wenn sie es doch besser wissen?
Zweitens ist, wer definiert ab wann man was wortwörtlich nimmt, was da drin steht und
ab wann nicht und wer hat so die Deutungshoheit darüber, es gibt zum Beispiel im Nahen Osten
sicherlich nicht wenige, die der Meinung sind, dass man den Koran wortwörtlich auslegen
muss und auch in den USA haben wir letztens ein Video gesehen, in den USA gibt es Leute,
die sagen, die Bibel muss wortwörtlich genommen werden und Noahs Flut hat den Grand Canyon
in unter einer Woche erschaffen, gibt es Leute, die behaupten das, weil das so in der Bibel
steht, das ist halt, sobald du anfängst davon abzuweichen, hast du noch größere Erklärungsnöte,
als du ohnehin schon hast, deswegen verstehe ich nicht, wie man das, das, das kriegt man
nicht unter, unter einen Hut, ja, was hältst du von WordPress, ähm, an sich nicht schlecht,
WordPress ist ja berühmt, berüchtigt da, ähm, gucken wir mal, gibt es sich irgendwo
eine schöne Übersichtsseite, was so in WordPress 2021 war, wieso wenig, wie, das ist alles,
das ist aber viel zu wenig für WordPress, die hatten nur 8 Sicherheitslücken im Jahr,
WordPress ist doch berühmt, berüchtigt dafür, dass es löchrig ist wie so ein Schweizer
Käse, aber gut, immerhin einmal Code Execution, ja, die Plugins, das kommt noch dabei, ich
weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, wie schlimm es ist mittlerweile, ich habe WordPress schon
seit Jahren nicht mehr selbst verwendet, geschweige, also selbst verwendet habe ich es noch nie,
habe ich es auch nicht mal administrieren müssen, was, WordPress, habe ich das falsche,
ok, zeig mal her, ja gut, und was in 2021, davon, achso, 2021, oh ja, das ist ja ein
Busyverse, wie viel sind denn das, kann man das zählen lassen, wenn ich zählen werde,
wenn ich, wenn ich, oh Mist, äh, wenn ich das jetzt mal zählen, schnell, wie viel sind
denn das, lass mal kurz, lass mal kurz, Wim, Wim, Magic, mach, wobei, ich brauche, ups,
ich hab, ich hab was, setpaste
so
was hier?
save as
wordpress.cacw
wc-l
wordpress.
913 Sicherheitslücken in 2021
ja das ist eher mein wordpress so wie ich kenne
ja das bewegt sich 913 das bewegt sich eher in dem in der größten ordnung wie ich mir das vorgestellt hätte
ich glaube daran dass c++ eine gute sprache ist, siehste?
das ist wieder ein schönes beispiel daran muss man nicht glauben wir wissen mittlerweile dass c++ kacke ist
keinerlei raum für irgendwelche glaubensspekulationen
ich habe, ihr werdet es nicht glauben, ich habe einen
eine c++ konn vortrag gesehen
wo ich mir wieder gedacht habe
was zum teufel
ist mit c++ los
glaub das da
so allein schon wenn man den titel liest
und dann solche dinger da sieht
ne das war der vortrag nicht
das war das war das nicht war was anderes
keine ahnung zumindest habe ich wieder gefragt was zum teufel macht das c++ cremium da
und ein weiterer nachteil bei c++ ist ja selbst wenn das cremium mal einen neuen standard verabschiedet
bis der jemals wenn überhaupt
in allen compilern und plattformen drauf ist vergehen eh 100 jahre
weiß ich ob wir sehen werden
ich weiß nicht ob wir es erleben werden dass in nächster zeit dass alle c++ 20 features
implementiert sind sowohl in gcc als auch in der wishlist studio geschichte und sonstiges im leben nicht
die haben dann immer irgendwelche eigenheiten davon noch
das ist grausam
ja das ist richtig die sache ist nur die
wenn das in konflikt gerät also stell dir mal vor du bist naturwissenschaftler
und du weißt mit an sicherheit grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit
dass die welt nicht in sieben tagen erschaffen wurde
was machst du dann
glaubst du das dann trotzdem
oder nicht
wo fängt es an und wo hört es auf
das stelle ich mir als unglaublich schwierig vor
deswegen bin ich auch davon ausgegangen dass da mal so in technischen berufen und gerade auch in naturwissenschaften
religiosität nicht so verbreitet ist weil ich nicht mir vorstellen kann
wie die leute das unter einen hau und unter eine haube bringen wollen
c++ ist gut wenn man sich in jahr 2000 zurück versetzt
vielleicht wobei man da auch hätte parzell bleiben können
das ist zwar manche sachen umständliche aber wenigstens klarer
ja gut du kannst ja auch deine eigene religion zurecht machen
wie das beispielsweise die wie gesagt glaube die zeugen jehovas sind die was man von alien raum schiffen erzählen klar
du kannst dir immer was was eigenes überlegen was der sache da nicht widerspricht
fünf jahre später gibt es neue erkenntnisse wieder was was nicht passt
das funktioniert einfach nicht
das ist dann halt immer schwierig ich kenne das ich kenne meine mutter ist auch
großartig gläubig aber schon in die richtung die erzählt auch immer so sachen und wenn man dann fragt
ok wo fängt es dann an und wo hört das auf ja irgendwann weiß man ja nicht so genau
heute ist das d ausgebaut die schraube im gehäuse verloren pc einschalten boom netzteil kaputt keck weh
nee nicht keck weh ich würde eher sagen monka smoke
oder gut ich meine für uns keck weh für dich vielleicht nicht jetzt weiß ich wo die alte wo die
wo die wo die alte weiß ich mich auf alte gekäupt wo die schraube geblieben ist
ja im netzteil wahrscheinlich
oder war das sein tolles je mit den mit den aliens ich kann es gibt irgendeine
glaubensgemeinschaft die ist der meinung wenn die welt untergeht kommen die aliens
und nehmen uns im raum schiff mit könnte durchaus sein tolles je sein könnten auch die zeugen
jehovas ansonsten was man muss ja mehr ehrlich sagen vom ansatz her ist es alles schwachsinn
das nimmt sich ja nichts das das was sich was nimmt ist was die ganzen
ja vereine da oder gemeinschaften daraus machen unterm strich dass die mormonen ich habe keine
ahnung letztendlich ist auch egal es gibt welche und das ist schon merkwürdig genug
guckst du dart wm nee spielt da marcel scorpion mit mittlerweile
wahrscheinlich spielt er da nicht mit aber ich weiß dass der sich voll für dart interessiert hat mal vor
der weile gibt es den überhaupt noch auf youtube mein youtube marcel scorpion prostitution wo ist er denn
gibt es den noch wie der gibt es nicht mehr wo ist er denn hin darts hier wo ist er denn hin
ah ja hier ist er noch am start ok reaction videos nice wer hätte das gedacht darts
ich fasse nicht reaction videos reaction videos geht immer gut angebot und nachfrage
genau ich darf nicht sagen ich habe auch letztens in reaction video hochgeladen hast du schon mal
judemikurse gemacht ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es in judemikurs war aber es könnte sein
ich habe mir damals den mba gs kurs gekauft als man noch nichts von react und view bei frontend
frameworks wusste und ich sage euch mba gs ist der komplizierte abfuck aller Zeiten ich habe damit nie
wirklich was gemacht über basics hinaus weil es so unglaublich unintuitiv war
3d drucker gepimpt
ist das ist das ein i3 mega sieht vom display ähnlich aus
gepimpt heißt du hast dir selbst so einen eigenen lüfter gehäuse gedruckt dafür
ja gut wie gesagt das kann ja jeder machen was er will ist ja sein gutes recht aber nachvollziehen
muss ich das ja dann nicht aus singapur
inwiefern was kam denn bei euch an hatte tp requests oder was mit irgendwie log von j
geschichten im payload oder oder was port 80 ja dass die china chinesen da schon abgehen in
der richtung das war ja klar
c plus ja das fehlt noch holi c gibt es noch ja das funktioniert aber auch nicht so wirklich
weil der ist aber so der erkenntnishorizont verschiebt sich ja immer und das hast du
gesehen dort wo man noch an 100 vor 100 jahren fest dran geklaut hat hat sich heute rausgestellt
also naja mittlerweile kann man es erklären und es ergibt nicht viel sinn woran man geklaut
hat glaubst du rast wird sich gegen c++ durchsetzen zu nein also kommt drauf an in welchem
welchem bereich ich glaube nicht dass rast jemals c++ ablösen wird weil gerade im gaming
bereich gerade wenn man sich unreal anguckt ist halt c++ das ding schlechthin es gibt
auch viele große projekte wie cute für für guise und was in c++ die wird es nicht alles
in rast geben aber im embedded bereich finde ich das persönlich ganz nice wenn rast also
ich fände es zum beispiel cool könnte mich könnte ich mein esp 32 mit rast programmieren
anstatt mit c++ rast ist halt auch ein bisschen abfuck weil rast eben sehr pingelig ist was
compiler sachen angeht dafür funktioniert in der regel dein scheiß man kann nicht sagen
fehlerfrei weil du kannst ja immer noch logik fehler haben aber zumindest funktioniert
in rast der kram so wie er da steht meistens wenn du dann ausführst wenn natürlich logik
fehler drin ist nicht aber es macht das was da steht das ist bei c++ nicht zwangsläufig
so aha nexo style war danke für den sub wie kamst du zu deinem twitch nickname das war
irgendwas random spontanes und ich habe den twitch account erstellt bevor ich streamen
wollte ich war damit schon lange auf die jahre auf twitch unterwegs und ich habe ziemlich
blöde sachen auf twitch geschrieben also falls mal einer nach den falls es irgendwie chat
logs gibt oder so keine ahnung also nichts anstößiges oder so halt dummes twitch gespamme
das würde ich heute mit dem account nicht mehr machen das kann ich verstehen gerade
wenn man server im internet stehen hat bisschen paranoia ist aber auch nicht verkehrt ganz
ehrlich ich habe beispielsweise total oft den prozess explorer im hintergrund laufen
dass ich mit bekomme was bei mir auf dem rechner so los ist ist zwar schwachsinn es sei denn
der chat ist wieder heute richtig hacker man unterwegs und hackt mein chat über über
hackt mein rechner über den twitch chat aber ansonsten ist beschwachsinnig aber ich weiß
trotzdem gerne was im hintergrund läuft was abgeht kann ich kann ich komplett nachvollziehen
idee zu was 3d trucker was achso hier dazu nö bisschen paranoia ist nicht verkehrt ich
mein du kannst dir im zweifelsfall natürlich ein bisschen monitoring einrichten was guckt
angemeldete user cpu auslastung sowas in der richtung
nee das problem ist rust ist in sich schlüssig c++ nicht was benutze ich für eine tastatur
bin gerade auf der suche nach einer fürs tippen im homeoffice ein bisschen zu zocken
habe ich also ich habe aktuell hier eine logitech so gute frage was es für eines chat ihr wisst
wahrscheinlich besser als ich was ist das für ein tastatur logitech g 512 die 512 die
ist aber nicht gut weil die erste habe ich schon verschlissen da ist die controltaste
einfach abgebrochen warum ich die habe liegt daran weil ich die macrosoftware von logitech
mag auf der arbeit habe ich das hier der arbeit habe ich eine ducky one skyline allerdings
die variante hier mit numblock sieht genauso aus wie da auf dem bild
könntest du dir vorstellen selbst mal tastatur zusammen bauen ja könnte ich aber ich wüsste
nicht warum der felix bei mir von der arbeit hat sich
letztens eine tastatur selbst zusammengebaut hat mir auch ein paar photos von gepostet so
eine mini tastatur ist das ist quasi nur dieser teil hier irgendwie von der tastatur so ganz
merkwürdig klein richtig kleines mini teil natürlich mit rgb und sonst was was er sich
da gebaut hat an sich eine coole geschichte aber ich dann es kann sein dass das das ist
tatsächlich möglich möglich dass das sowas in der richtung ist ja sowas ja aber ich habe
den sinn für mich da drin nicht gesehen ehrlich gesagt 60 prozent keyboard keine ahnung es
ist ich habe den sinn nicht erkannt für mich da drin also die zwei sachen kann ich halt
aus erster hand berichten also wie gesagt einmal die g512 logitech die habe ich hier
daheim davor hatte ich eine corsar die war richtig räudig beschissen sage ich so wie
es ist corsar k95 oder sowas war das das war richtiger müll so mit doppelten tasten anschlägen
und sowas ganz ganz großer mist und auf der arbeit habe ich die was das belldelfin keyboard
ach ja endlich denn da haben wir alle drauf gewartet leute da haben wir ja drauf gewartet
hier das belldelfin keyboard endlich jetzt weiß ich auch was ich für eine tastatur
kauf danach die belldelfin combo moment warum kostet das monatlich warum kostet das monatlich
warum im alles in der welt kostet das monatlich warum muss ich für das belldelfin monatlich
bezahlen raten wahrscheinlich ich trau mich nicht leute ich trau mich nicht weiter runter
zu scrollen ich trau mich nicht weiter runter zu scrollen auf der seite tos wahrscheinlich
ja ich sag euch leute bald brauchen wir gar keine tastatur mehr dann benutzen wir alle
keyboard as a service wie auch immer das funktionieren soll irgend einer wird schon erfinden
bestes emote hier gachi roll ich habe das emote letztens auf dem anderen channel gesehen
hat mir gedacht das brauche ich gachi roll
slash exploit klingt ziemlich nach china chinesen hacker wir bräuchten eigentlich noch eine
china variante davon können wir da nicht einfach irgendwie so eine rote rote fahne drüber
machen oder so eine rote fahne overlayen ist dann ein china hacker man und rote fahne funktioniert
gleichermaßen auch da haben wir zwei fliegen mit einer klappe geschlagen das funktioniert
auch für den computer man müsste es einfach nur rot machen das können sowohl die chinesen
als auch die russin dann sein da haben wir zwei to in one heckermann und den normalen
matrix heckermann haben wir ja auch noch was du würdest den raspberry pi austauschen für
was habe ich irgendwas übersehen bei meinem alten raspberry pi 1 färbt sich die platine
gelblich das ist nicht schlimm in der regel in raucher haushalten war das früher noch
viel schlimmer das ist meistens nicht schlimm nichts schlimmes du kannst es theoretisch
wahrscheinlich sogar mit bisschen alkohol oder so sauber machen wenn du willst aber
wozu alternativ kannst du einfach die sd karte rausnehmen und den neuen wobei moment
moment raspberry pi 1 ist der raspberry pi 1 nicht noch am v6 beides ist egal die neuen
kernels sind da ja auch drauf ok dann wird die neun würde ich trotzdem vielleicht mal
neu installieren aber ich glaube nicht dass sie da gedanken machen muss domeswap dankeschön
für den zapp weiß nicht ja wie gesagt die habe ich auf der arbeit seit 2 oder 3 jahren
also ich hatte die schon eine ganze weile vor corona das heißt müssen jetzt ja eigentlich
zwei jahre sein mindestens eher drei und rein zum arbeiten ist sie gut ich kann dir noch
ein tipp zu geben zu dieser tastatur die ist mechanisch und relativ laut und wenn du die
auf der arbeit verwendest dann könnte das sein dass kollegen voll die abgefuckt sind
ich habe mir da für die tasten wo ich neige ihr wisst ja ich neige zum beispiel extrem
den num block enter zu hauen und sowas in der richtung und auch linkes linker control
knopf und sowas ist auch was wo ich gerne drauf haue ich habe da so silikonringe unter
speziellen tasten das ist nicht so sehr bumst kann ich kann ich empfehlen nicht überall
drunter das macht ja den sinn von der mechanischen tastatur schon wieder irgendwie ein bisschen
stellt das in frage aber unter manche tasten wo man dazu neigt besonders fest drauf zu
hauen finde ich das finde ich das nicht verkehrt
stimmt leute die 5g antenne haben wir schon im armen
weiß ich ob ich eine enter taste so als rage kissen irgendwie
ne dann würde ich mir lieber ein
ein anime body pillow kaufen alter das aber jetzt schon wirklich grenzwertig hier was
aber amazon gibt alter jetzt wird es aber langsam sehr grenzwertig tos wenn das bei amazon drauf
ist da ist er nichts tos aber es geht schon auf jeden fall in die tos richtung ja wir
hätten jetzt nicht gedacht dass man aber amazon nicht danach suchen kann ja hätte ich
nicht mit gerechnet so ja leute wir gucken jetzt noch mal ein bisschen auf youtube was
haben wir denn hier so schönes ihr seid euren lieblings entwicklern egal gewöhnt euch dran
wenn maurice das sagte hat er wahrscheinlich recht maurice hat oftmals recht in seinen
videos und was ich cool finde warum wahrscheinlich ist auch der grund warum ich die videos von
maurice ganz gerne kucke meistens geht das was ich eh schon denke und das was er sagt
in die ähnliche richtung deswegen es ist ja oft so dass man sich leute sucht die ähnliche
sachen zu dem erzählen was man eh schon quasi denkt und das guckt man dann gerne
ach guck mal level cap ach guck mal das ist ein schlecht bewertetes level cap video es
gibt jetzt zwei sachen warum das schlecht bewertet sein kann entweder weil die fanboys
angepisst sind dass er die wahrheit sagt über das wie über das spiel oder weil die leute
angepisst sind dass er es zu positiv beschreibt aber elf minuten können wir uns mal angucken
wahrscheinlich ist es aber typisches level cap gbaton der redet wahrscheinlich einfach
zwölf minuten im kreis ich gebe ihm mal zwei drei minuten die chance aber wenn er sich
dann zwei drei minuten nur im kreis redet dann wird das nix level cap streamt wisst
ihr was ich interessant finde ok ich wollte gerade sagen level cap hat weniger zuschauer
als ich auf twitch gehabt beim battlefield streamen das kann ja nicht sein wobei das
auch der beweis dafür ist dass youtube einfach eine kacke streaming plattform ist lo du
siehst noch dislikes gibt zwei varianten entweder haben die die dislikes progressiv
jetzt deaktiviert dass es nicht überall ist weil ich weiß sie wollten das eigentlich
machen ne ne ne das plugin kann das auch nicht überall herziehen oder für dieses video
gibt es noch welche sie haben sich dislikes im vorfeld von dem video gespeichert was
er nicht sein kann ist vom 20 december oder das hier ist irgendeine errechnetes dislike
verhältnis wobei ich das an der stelle gar nicht mal glaube gucken wir mal gucken wir
mal was level cap zu sagen hat die dislike api sollte glaube ich am zwölften oder so
schon abgeschaltet werden kann aber sein dass ich mich vertuere da jetzt
ja manche sachen die einfach nur komplett broken waren sind jetzt ein wenig weniger
procken aber massively improved ist vielleicht dann etwas zu viel des guten es gab überhaupt
nichts erwähnenswertes außer vielleicht ihre ihre rush geschichte egal egal ich lasse ihn
jetzt mal reden das liegt doch daran leute die das spiel jetzt spielen hat ja den grund
warum die das spielen wenn sie das nicht zumindest ein bisschen enjoyen würden würden sie nicht
spielen es ist überhaupt nicht hart dann ein read draus zu bekommen 95 prozent ist einfach
negativ und ja auch nicht einfach nur irgendwie auf gefühlsbasis oder so du kannst ja auch
die punkte ganz klar benennen wie das da ist zum beispiel sagt scoreboard sind ein legacy
feature das hat ja noch nichts mal mit gefühl zu tun das ist ja fakt
das heißt ja nichts das heißt ja insofern nichts die anderen games waren zwar auch kaputt
aber keines war so extrem borderline vom designer im arsch und borderline unplayable wie battlefield
22 42 selbst battlefield 4 nicht so far and this again is speaking for my personal experience
but they fixed basically all of the connectivity issues with getting onto servers a lot of
the performance and lag stuttering issues was they have gefixed dass du das spiel jetzt
spielen kannst ja gut job they fixed and or balanced most of the weapons impressively fast
and they fix some of the ui quality of life issues though there's still some work to be
done there and they've also updated the breakthrough maps that had borderline impassable objectives
das stimmt objectives are new locations now all that besser sind sie trotzdem nicht data
mine seems to indicate that we may not get dice's first season of content ja das hat
tom henderson auch geleakt das kann ich mir auch durchaus vorstellen man muss sich das
mal überlegen die bringen ein spiel im november raus in einem absolut desaströsen desolaten
zustand haben eigentlich nix zu bieten und wollen die nächste season wo dann auch nicht
viel kommt muss man ja dazu sagen da kommt irgendwie eine map und was ich mal ein specialist
kommt es kommt eine map und mit ein paar waffen oder so im märz starten what the fuck bis dahin
ist das spiel tot ja klar es spielt jetzt schon keiner die spieler zahlen die letzten
zwei drei tage waren deutlich besser weil free weekend ist aber selbst free weekend
kann er nicht drüber hinweg täuschen gucken wir doch mal steam ja da ist nix hängen geblieben
großartig vom free weekend nahezu nichts ok wir waren schon mal runter auf 10.000 letztens
waren wir rund auf 16.000 ok ok man muss sagen das sind nicht die absoluten spieler zahlen
da fehlt origin und die konsole natürlich aber der trend ist ja das um den es geht
line up with passgames dlc's timelines ist still quite a ways off especially if it's
only one new map a few new ends maybe a single new specialist again the data mine information
is unconfirmed ich habe nie großartig fortnite gespielt aber ihr erinnert euch doch bestimmt
noch an dieses event mit dem schwarzen loch und sowas die haben das richtig gut gemacht
bei epic games und fortnite du warst permanent begeistert dieses spiel zu spielen es kam
permanent dinger die die die die leute eben gehyped haben permanent neu die haben das
richtig gut gemacht das muss man muss man auch mal sehen und da kann man auch nicht
die augen davor verschließen man hat gesehen dass das erfolgreich funktionieren kann aber
da muss halt auch der content dazu passen und die leute wissen was sie treiben und ich hab
es noch zu pupke zeiten gesagt als pupke grad den ultra high part ich hab gesagt leute
ich gehe davon aus demnächst wird fortnite vorne sein und es war dann auch so ich will
jetzt nicht sagen maxi der große prophet aber es gibt halt einfach sachen die sind irgendwie
wenn man ein bisschen ein bisschen langjährige erfahrung in games hat drängen sich auf gewisse
vermutungen ja ich habe auch oft genug falsch gelegen ich habe zum beispiel rainbow six
nach release also sie komplett wieder abgeschrieben da haben sie gezeigt hey das kann man durchaus
was draus machen aber also ist jetzt schwer zu sagen wir können wir können es nicht
überprüfen aber ich könnte fast wetten wenn mir einer und wir müssen das echt mal für
nächstes jahr machen ich gucke mir 20 gelbe projekte an und ich kann euch sagen ob das
was taugt am ende oder nicht also mein persönlicher eindruck vielleicht denke ich aber auch dass
ich zu big brain bin ist dass ich relativ oft richtig liege ich habe auch schon beim ersten
anthem trailer gesagt alter das wird nix leute
jetzt muss ich mir gerade nochmal an und ich habe richtig zugehört wisst ihr was die fanboys
da sagen so nach dem motto das gibt in dem spiel nichts die sagen ja dann erstell doch
einen portal server ja klar portal ist die antwort für alles
ja der da der bar der bumm du meinst das von tom henderson das video wahrscheinlich
das haben wir uns ja auch schon zusammen angeguckt das wirklich gut
einfach es ich bin ja schon so weit im spiel dass ich sage es muss kein server browser
sein eigentlich müsste es ein server browser sein aber wir werden ja schon damit geholfen
könnte man einfach maps abwählen die man nicht spielen will das problem ist nur dass
fast alle maps scheiße sind was für maps bleibt da noch übrig die man spielen will
was was was bleibt übrig was von den maps willst du wirklich auf diesen offenen heli
verseuchten maps spielen wenn du battlefield infanterie spieler bist was was was willst
du tun würde der echte gangster jetzt sagen am ehesten noch manifest und orbital oder
sowas aber selbst die sind mittlerweile nicht mehr richtig spielbar eigentlich keine wenn
wir mal ehrlich sind welche will man spielen
die monotonie des having to play your least favorite maps back to back also if they could
patch in some of the games most requested features like an in game scoreboard that would
probably go a long ways while waiting for content legacy feature now that we have hindsight
on the games launch i think there's some things we can say with almost 100 percent certainty
about what happened firstly 2042 launched early and could have used more time i think i'm
going out on a limb they are making that statement but we are ahead of schedule there's many
debates as to how much time the game could have needed
mindestens ein ja ich sag euch wie es ist mindestens ein ja und dann aber auch nur unter der voraussetzung
man hätte das game zu einem guten battlefield noch umkrempeln wollen dann ein ja mindestens
das stimmt wohl ja selbst schuld
das war überhaupt nicht getestet da war nix getestet richtig dran aber wozu sollte man
auch geld fürs testen ausgeben wenn man doch jetzt ein paar hunderttausend quasi kostenlose
tester more time nicht nur kostenlose tester sogar tester die geld dafür bezahlen tester
zu sein interesting to me and also this is further backed up with reports from tom henderson
that the game was primarily tested with 60 to 70 player test environments which would
obviously lead to issues with balance and flow many of which the game still struggles with
such as lack of cover and maps that are simply too good and aber die maps denn auch mit 64
spieler scheiße kann man ja gerade ausprobieren open and not well thought out for the number
of players however regarding the bones of the game i do think that we're in a much better
place that is the best corner wenn man keine fehler macht dann muss man auch nicht testen
vorher also man sieht battlefield 2042 ist die schwedische art keine fehler zu machen
compared to say battlefield 5 launch it took battlefield five about a year before it even
felt like it was in a place to begin if you don't know what you're supposed to do three
months and if that's the hardest to make no mistake remember that that game barely had functional
progression trees and totally untested aerial combat and other things on launch day with
battlefield 2042 i think the game is just about ready to start moving forward about a month
after launch and sure there's more balance work needed but the bones are there and now
it just needs more weapon refinement map updates some of which the game has already received
and we need more content for the base game which is clearly planned but hopefully we
don't have to wait until march ich sehe das nicht so positiv as mentioned before some
in-game features like a scoreboard would be some nice quality ich gehe davon aus das
spiel ist komplette totgeburt die werden irgendwann sommern nächsten jahres ankündigen dass
das ja sie können ja schlecht aus der ding aus der nummer raus also die mindestsachen
die sie versprochen haben werden sie bringen ich gehe davon aus dass nächstes jahr im
sommer oder dahin noch mal versucht wird mit quasi hinterher geworfenen battlefield 2042
lizenzen oder keys und downloads da noch ein bisschen was rumzureißen und dann wird spätestens
ende des sommers oder anfangen anfangen des winters wenn absehbar ist dass da nichts mehr
geht wird verkündet werden die zukunftspläne für das spiel und das wird dann so schön wie
sie es immer machen umschrieben es wird dann nicht gesagt leute wir stellen den support ein
es ist ja dass es also der trend aktuell ist ja quasi nicht das zu sagen was man eigentlich
sagen will also wenn man sagen will heutzutage marketing staunchstechnisch wir stellen den
support für battlefield ein dann schreibt man nicht wir stellen den support für battlefield
ein nein man schreibt man hat die beste community und battlefield hat genau great future ahead
schreiben sie genau das wollte ich gerade sagen die schreiben dann das spiel hat eine großartige
zukunft vor sich ihr müsst euch mal die meldung beispielsweise von blizzard angucken wo sie über
nacht heroes of the storm e-sport eingestampft haben das ist auch so ein bullshit text gewesen
ja das ist das ist heute so du schreibst nicht du stellst den support für das game ein du
schreibst dass das game eine tolle zukunft vor sich hat und du weiterhin voll committed
bist und so ein bullshit aber zwischen den zeilen kann jeder erkennen das spiel ist dead und ich
denke mal das spätestens ende nächsten jahres aber ich denke schon fast wechsel so erbst richtung
winter nächsten jahres wenn man wenn es denn so ist dass es im sommer sicher nicht retten lassen
oder gefangen hat oder noch ein paar verramschte copies das jetzt rumreißen können dass das dann
schon nächstes jahr soweit sein wird sie müssen das mindeste liefern was sie zugesichert haben
das werden sie wahrscheinlich auch machen aber wir werden spätestens ende nächsten jahre sehen
wenn halt der der plan kommt wie es weiter laufen soll naja also ich denke das ist eigentlich schon
gelaufen ich glaube nicht dass ich das spiel davon wirklich wieder erholen wird kann sein dass ich
falsch liege mit rainbow six habe ich auch komplett daneben gelegen da habe ich auch gedacht alter
totgeburt aber ich bin mir ein paar bettel viel deutlich sicherer als bei 6 weil ich eben
selbstausführlich gespielt habe schauen wir mal denke nicht dass sie die kurve bekommen ich glaube
das ist vorbei prüfen jetzt jetzt auch so binden pointen dass der baufeil 2042 hat
sich die spieler base ziemlich schnell ja recent sale und freies weekend hat sie auch nur auf sieben
tage leute ich habe das ja eben hier mal offen ist sofort ich habe das ja hier mal offen gehabt eben
nicht new world das ist auch so ein ding ich habe es ja eben ich hatte sie eben offen gehabt wenn
ihr das mal hier hinstellt das ist halt richtig krass das geht von 100.000 runter auf ungefähr
11.000 und dann kommt hier free weekend die spieler zahlen sollten dich aber insofern jucken wenn du
dir weitere patches und content für das spiel erwartest das kann man ja nicht irgendwie los
gelöst von allem betrachten ich meine es mag schön und gut sein wenn auch fünf leute das spiel
spielen oder wahnsinnig dran spaß haben aber da wird sie in dem spiel nichts mehr tun für alle
die das spiel mögen und wollen dass das weiter support die können eigentlich nur hoffen dass
sich noch mehr leute finden die das ähnlich sehen ja die zehntausend spieler stimmen ja nicht ganz
da fehlt origin dabei und da fehlen die konsolen bei also das werden schon deutlich mehr sein aber
der trend ist halt deutlich war back up compared to what it used to be but it was a substantial drop
overall and it's not to say that other big AAA titles with big marketing pre-launch don't lose a
lot of their player base after lunch this was just been a little more drastic to put things into
more context halo infinite which has been extremely well received overall das stimmt 72
percent of its player base in a pretty comparable da dass das ist richtig da würde mich aber in
dem fall tatsächlich mal die xbox zahlen interessieren weil halo schon seit jahren
ein xbox dinges aber ja hey es ist auch kein wunder dass halo das ja halo kommt gut aber es
ist auch kein wunder dass halo spieler zahlen verliert die machen auch nicht wirklich genug
um die spieler zu halten die haben ein komisches event gestartet was jetzt nicht sonderlich gut
angekommen ist und haben einen season pass der hat zwar gute dinger aber 90 davon 90 prozent davon
sind dann auch trash also das wundert mich jetzt auch nett time to battlefield 20 42 launch
wer battlefield 20 42 would have lost 85 percent of its player base however 90 prozent 42 is actually
up now thanks to that sale and free weekend so it's closer to having lost 65 percent from its
all time peak again it's hard to judge these things halo being so well received das stimmt
überhaupt nicht battlefield 90 prozent verloren die sind runter von 100.000 auf 10 11.000
of its peak player account versus battlefield losing a little bit more und mal ganz davon
abgesehen das macht es ja nicht besser nur weil andere spieler auch abkacken
to the free weekend slash sale it's hard to quantify it all i think we just really need
to observe it over a slightly longer period of time how the player base is going to fare
in the long run tommy kann ich kann ich verstehen kann ich verstehen ich hab new world ja auch zur
belustigung verfolgt ich hab new world die beta gespielt und im prinzip kann sie dass ich mein
video anhören auch so ein ding genau das was ich meine video gesagt habe von wegen endgame content
und sonst was genau so ist es ja dann im endeffekt im spiel auch gewesen habe ich ja auch richtig
gelegen mit und ich hab new world verfolgt weil ich new world sehr witzig fand die phase wo
jeden tag neue game breaking bugs rausgekommen sind und wo nun wo amazon es quasi tagtäglich
verkackt hat mit irgendwelchen patches patches die andere sachen kaputt gemacht haben und sachen die
sie fixen wollten nicht richtig gefixt haben spielertransfere wo gold dupliziert werden konnte
und sonst was ich habe täglich ist ungelungen ich habe täglich bestimmt drei vier wochen lang
täglich new world news verfolgt ich hab ich ich hing den quasi an den lippen den leuten die
nu die new world news gemacht haben auf youtube weil ich das so unterhaltsam fand die den kompletten
clusterfuck und die fuck ups von amazon zu sehen bei new world die overall community sentiment
again people are still highly divided there's definitely a lot of people that are just angry
about the game and some of the design decisions made and some of the performance problems
especially on last gen consoles but for people who are enjoying the game and i do lump myself
into this category ja das sagt er jetzt weil die leute sonst sich übelste aufregend wahrscheinlich
pretty darn fun and i don't like feeling guilty about having to say that i'm enjoying nein musste
auch nicht wenn es dir spaß macht ist ja gut dann kriegste wenigstens ein bisschen was von deinem
geld gut du hast man der wahrscheinlich genauso mich auch gekriegt aber das ist ja ok weil will
er keinem schlechtes gewissen machen weil er das spiel gut findet aber trotzdem heißt das nicht
dass das spiel keine probleme hat das muss man ja immer trennen das fällt mir bei sachen die ich
gut finde auch immer schwierig fällt mir auch immer schwer bei sachen die ich persönlich richtig
gut finde dass man sagt ja ok ich habe da vielleicht mein spaß dran aber trotzdem darf
man nicht die augen davor verschließen dass es erstens bei ganz vielen leuten nicht der fall ist
und vor allem auch warum das so ist also muss man muss dann schon sehen ok das spiel hat viele
probleme nicht dass du draus darf das spiel natürlich jedem weiterhin spaß machen also
new world finde ich weitaus schlimmer als battlefield 2042 ja das stimmt gut ich meine
new world ist ja nur wirklich absolute untergrenze die dir kaum noch unterschreiten kannst aber vor
ein paar jahren hätte sich das sicherlich keiner denken lassen dass battlefield mal bei so einem
ding ankommt bei so einem alltime battlefield low aber battlefield ist auch schon ganz schön ganz
schön weit unten ja es ist nicht so beschissen gelaufen wie new world aber also es ist verfasst
es ist ja fast dieses jahr ein wettbewerb allerdings nicht nach oben sondern wer schlechter
sein kann ja dann kommt amazon macht new world dann sagt da ich sage wir können auch dann kommt
wenn gerade um die ecke ach wir können auch was was was gab es denn sonst noch dieses jahr für
für komische komische die wolzen alter kann sich an wolzen erinnern es war doch dieses jahr
oder war doch anfangen des jahres wolzen cyberpunk war ende letzten jahres ja wolzen das kennt
wahrscheinlich gar keiner mehr so schnell ist der halb gestorben bei wolzen ich weiß übrigens gar
nicht bis heute man wolzen überhaupt ausspricht mein dieses diablo clone ding wolzen wolzen
wolzen ich habe keine ahnung wie man das ausspricht aber egal weiter ja nintendo kackt ja auch wohl
öfters ab in letzter zeit also es ist es ist wirklich dieses jahr und auch in den letzten
jahren ist es eher so ein ein race to the bottom sozusagen und nicht wer ist besser die forcht
warcraft 3 die forcht gab es ja auch noch aber das ist letztes jahr das lassen wir jetzt mal
außen vor wenn wenn es danach geht gab es ja noch mehr von fallout 76 und anthem und dem
ganzen geschiss reden wir mal gar nicht ist just the fact of the matter i load up the game i have
fun while playing it i like doing the week i'm finding a lot of nuance involved with the specialist
system learning the best grappling spots with mckay finding good defensive areas with irish
and sundance's wingsuit antics are essentially neverending and also allein schon das da warum
warum ist das bot hier mit dem sniper direkt dem gegner spawn ich meine was ist das für
eine map also ich weiß wie die map heißt ich meine was ist für ein map design was ist
der gegner sparnet the game with a more class structured system it's certainly not something
that's at the tip of my mind while i'm playing plus the fact that vehicles are so darn powerful
in this game right now makes me hope that they at least let me keep the heli gestört till
they would have the vehicles if they are planning to further classify the specialist in this
game which they have not made any comments about so it's likely that a class system is not coming
down the road but who knows the lack of weapon variety in the game is starting to do best du bist
auf die firma von dr disrespect gespart ich wusste gar nicht dass sie den shooter entwickeln aber
was wir nicht vergessen dürfen dr disrespect war level designer für modern warfare 3 oder ghost
was wo war er noch mal dabei bei ghost oder bei einem call of duty war er dabei ob das so viel
besser wird mal gucken und i think it really depends just how much you're playing the game since it
does take a while to actually get all the guns unlocked but one nice thing right now is that
after the patch balances and updates every single gun könnt ihr nachgucken gibt immer noch leute
die da jedes mal überrascht sind aber das ich dachte eigentlich das ist mittlerweile ein bekannter
bekannter fact aber dr disrespect level designer für ja das ist ja ok er war in mw3 und advanced
warfare beteiligt oder anscheinend oder ja modern warfare 3 und advance warfare war am start
advanced warfare ja mal gucken ob man das jetzt besser hinkriegt
ok das wieder im kreis rum und wie das game mode anywhere i don't think there's very many
people playing it there's the only talk i see the trouble to actually try and get
something that i mentioned in my first impressions was so lame that it was gonna be dead on arrival and i'm sorry to say that that seems to have been pretty accurate regarding the live service for the game so far we've received two weeks worth of content two new weapon skins which i personally think are pretty decent and a few new game modes it certainly hasn't been monumental content but it's decent so far of course is drying
a bit more scrutiny because right now we runtergeschraubt die ansprüche sind ich meine er hört sich jetzt weder sondern ich begeistert an noch im prinzip heißt es ja das game kam halt richtig scheiß zustand raus und jetzt ist es immer noch scheiß aber ein bisschen weniger scheiß und eigentlich bin ich ganz zufrieden mit dass das game nicht mal ganz so kacke ist ja ok
really just needs to hit their live service content out of the park as opposed to just deliver noch die guten alten sagt der chat die guten alten dates tage nein ich habe dates nie gespielt fortunately though we haven't yet seen that scary santa skin pop up so my fingers are crossed that it wasn't really planned to come out or maybe it was
ging an mir vorbei die ganze zombie survival-geschichte ok level cap ist im prinzip da kommt nichts bei rum bei dem video jetzt das müssen wir uns nicht weiter angucken
ja mal gucken was sie machen sollen sie mal soll er mal was raushauen noch geld hat er ja
new battlefield 4 äh battlefield 4 leute mein gehirn funktioniert schon gar nicht mehr playstation 4 jailbreak das gucken wir uns jetzt auch an ich wusste gar nicht dass es einen neuen ps4 jailbreak gibt den könnte ich vielleicht bei meiner ps4 installieren weil meine ps4 hatte ich schon ewig nicht mehr an
ja tommy das kenne ich
eckermann time eckermanns den usb stick hatte auch schon jeder
ist laut genug erki danke für den sub so müsste es aber eigentlich passen oder?
dazu habe ich mich noch nicht weiter belesen
darf ich das auf stream? darf ich das streamen wie ich meine ps4 jailbreaker? bestimmt nicht oder?
ich glaube das darf man nicht streamen wenn man seine konsole jailbreak
ja da hast du gewonnen
ist das hier im hintergrund nicht dieses silent hill demo wo das spiel nie dazu erschienen ist?
oder ist das was anderes?
ja
Die Anleitung wird dir sagen, dass es für einen Payload warten wird.
Um das zu tun, können wir ein Tool genannt Netcat nutzen, um einen Homebrew-Enabler, wie Goldhand, zu den PS4 zu drücken.
Und das ist es, wir sind alle fertig.
Um zu double-checken, ob es funktioniert, geh in das System-Settings-Menü und du kannst Goldhand auf dem Topf der Liste sehen.
Und von hier kann das Spaß wirklich beginnen.
Jetzt muss man den FDP-Säuber starten.
Das ist kein Standalone-Jowel-Break.
Es braucht einen USB-Flash-Drive und einen PC, um den Payload zu drücken.
Gut, ich glaube, einen USB-Stick und einen PC, um das draufzumachen, das haben die meisten Leute.
Zumindest alle, die daran denken, ihre PS4 zu jailbreaken.
Wie alt ist der 9.0 als Firmware?
Also wie gesagt, ich hatte meine PS4 bestimmt zwei Jahre nicht mehr an.
Ich habe das noch, ich habe das noch auf meiner, ich glaube, ich hatte das auf der PS3 damals sogar drauf.
Oder war das PS4?
Ich habe die, ich habe die Demo noch drauf auf der, auf meiner, auf meiner PlayStation.
Was genau bringt ein Jailbreak?
Das offensichtlichste dürfte sein, dass du wahrscheinlich Sicherheitskopien laufen hast, laufen lassen kannst, weil ich mir da gar nicht so sicher bin.
Kann man, kann man damit Sicherheitskopien ausführen?
Selbstverständlich würde ich nur Sicherheitskopien ausführen, die ich von meinen eigenen Datenträgern ohne Umgehung des Kopierschutzes erstellt habe.
Auf andere Ideen würde ich nicht kommen, ohne Linux-Distributionen über Torrent runterladen.
Du kannst, also jetzt aber unabhängig davon, das einfachste, was du, das generellste, was du machen kannst nach einem Jailbreak ist, du kannst Custom Software ausführen.
Das kann alles sein im Endeffekt.
Ja, siehst du, Sicherheitskopien, jeder macht sowas nur mit Sicherheitskopien.
Na, da werden sich die ganzen Leute in Multiplayer-Spielen drüber freuen.
Ist das eigentlich, ähm, wie sieht es eigentlich, Chet, wie sieht es mit Warzone auf der PS5 aus, gibt es das da schon oder spielen die noch alle PS4?
Dann sind die Hacker-Mans jetzt ja überall.
Kann man mit Jailbreak überhaupt noch online spielen?
Das ist eine gute Frage, wenn die, wenn die, ähm, Firmenversion zu alt ist, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das ist eine gute Frage, keine Ahnung, also bei manchen Konsolen ja, bei manchen nein.
Ja, also zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel bei der Xbox 360 mit einem Mod-Chip, konntest du online spielen.
Wurdest aber höchstwahrscheinlich gebannt.
Ah, du musst den PSN sauber blocken wegen Updates, okay.
Gut, das wird mich jetzt, das wird mich persönlich jetzt nicht so schocken.
Gut, man könnte damit wahrscheinlich PSN-Trophys machen, indem man die offline anlockt und danach updatet.
Ob das, ob das jemals fertig wird, das Final Fantasy VII Remake?
Ich meine, die haben jetzt Remake quasi, ich sag mal übertrieben, das Intro des Spiels haben die jetzt über 5 Jahre oder so Remaked.
Der riesengroße Teil des Games ist ja da noch nicht mal im Ansatz zu erkennen.
Ob das jemals fertig wird?
Ja gut, das interessiert mich jetzt nicht.
Ja, das geht im Prinzip immer noch.
Moment, warum läuft da Half-Life drauf auf der PS?
Ist, das ist Blue Shift, oder?
Ja, das ist Blue Shift.
Interessant hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass man mittlerweile auch schon halb fix aktuelle PS modden kann.
Oder Jailbreaking.
Wahrscheinlich.
Mal gucken.
Remake 2 Part 2, wie sieht es denn damit aus?
Release Date Character.
Das ist wieder so eine Seite, die random Scheiß hinschreibt, obwohl sie es selbst nicht besser weiß.
Huge Rumors.
Ja, dann Huge Rumors, also Teil 2 gibt es dann 2030.
Und das heißt, das Spiel ist dann irgendwann mal fertig.
2045 oder so?
Ich glaube ja nicht, dass das jemals wird.
Nee, nee, nee, sowas mache ich nicht.
Wenn es Toss ist, mache ich das nicht, wäre ich ja blöd.
Keine Chance.
Können wir uns sonst noch angucken?
Wir gucken uns das Video von Maurice an, dem stimme ich meistens zu bei solchen Sachen.
Auf Maurice, erzähl uns die Neuigkeiten.
Ja, naja, kommt drauf an, mein Geld ist ihr nicht egal, ich schon.
Wenn ihr also dachtet, das Spielejahr 2021 war schon richtig schlimm, dann stellt euch
darauf ein, dass 2022 mindestens genauso schlimm, wenn nicht klar, noch schlimmer wird.
Ja, sehe ich genauso.
Man kann das sehr gut daran festmachen, dass wir ja vermutlich alle früher mal diesen
einen Lieblingsentwickler hatten, von dem wir jedes Spiel guten Gewissens.
Also mein mit Abstand Lieblingsentwickler, wisst ihr ja alle, ist, ich finde ihn immer
nicht in meinen Emotes, selbstverständlich Lord Garben, blind gekauft haben.
Und wenn man sich heute fragt, welchem dieser Entwickler von früher kann man heute noch
genauso blind vertrauen, dann bleibt nicht mehr viel.
Na gut, sagen wir mal so, die von früher nicht, ja, aber es gibt durchaus, und das
muss ich mir auch selbst immer wieder in Erinnerung rufen, gerade wenn man auf Steam guckt, bei
jetzt nicht von riesengroßen Studios, da gibt es durchaus gute Games, Nintendo, Quatsch,
was meinst du, was für was bei Nintendo abgeht und wie die Leute sich da überschlagen, bei
den Pokémon Games, dass die alles sucken zum größten Teil, bei Nintendo ist es auch
schon schon lange nichts mehr, du kannst nicht darauf verlassen, dass da was Gutes rauskommt.
Was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen, ja, es gibt ja immer noch gute Spiele, es geht ja
hauptsächlich um AAA Titel, jetzt auch wahrscheinlich denke ich mal, dass es ihnen in dem Video
da zum größten Teil darum geht, wo du zum größten Teil nur noch verarscht wirst, aber
es gibt auf Steam immer noch gute Games, zum Beispiel eines meiner Lieblingsgames in letzter
Zeit, das macht wirklich Bock, wie auch sowas wie Theme Park oder so steht, ist das wirklich
nice, ich finde auch den Grafikstil niedlich, normalerweise sage ich ja, alter es gibt so
viele Spiele mit Pixel Art, aber die haben das wirklich nett gemacht, man kann es jetzt
natürlich nicht mit AAA Games wie Battlefield oder sowas vergleichen, aber ich finde es
macht Spaß, also Kreativität gibt es da ja noch, bei mir war es zum Beispiel BioWare,
wo ich nach Anthem nie wieder blind kaufen würde, bei euch war es vielleicht, was macht
Anthem 2.0 eigentlich, das wurde eingestellt ne, ja ja stimmt, Bethesda, CD Projekt, Rockstar,
alles Firmen wo man heute sagen muss, DICE, nee, da muss ich vorsichtiger sein, denn es
hat sich industrieweit eine neue Mentalität durchgesetzt, es haben sich vor allem Stonks
Anzugträger in der Chefetage durchgesetzt und keine Gamer mehr, Blizzard hat früher
Spiele quasi von Spielern für Spieler, ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen platt ausgedrückt,
aber von Gaming Enthusiasten, von Gamern die Spiele mögen, für Gamer die Spiele mögen
entwickelt und wann habt ihr früher Spiele bekommen, zum Beispiel von Blizzard, die haben
ja geprägt diese Geschichte mit It's done when it's done, das gibt es heute nicht mehr,
heute hauen die so eine Kacke wie Warcraft 3 Deforged raus, weil irgendwelche Business
Stonks Manager gesagt haben, Jungs, jetzt muss aber mal raus und was die auch gesagt
haben ist, das Spiel bleibt jetzt so, an Warcraft 3, wenn ich das so verfolge, tut sich kaum
noch was, gibt es in Warcraft 3 eigentlich mittlerweile ohne Third Party irgendeine gescheite
Ladder?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, wahrscheinlich immer noch nicht, ich spiele das nicht, aber ich
verfolge es immer so ein bisschen am Rande.
Raushauen und wenn sie kaputt sind, dann können wir das immer noch fixen, wenn wir von den
Leuten das Geld dafür bekommen haben, oder man lässt es einfach so wie es ist, man merkt
finde ich mehr und mehr, das sind keine einzelnen Ausrutscher mehr, die Industrie hat sich in
relativ großer Masse dazu entschieden, dass das absolut akzeptabel ist, ja und die Leute
machen mit und die Fanboys des Monats machen mit, das ist ja gerade das Schlimme, das ist
das, was ich auch in meinem Video gesagt habe, wo so Battlefield 2042 ging, dass umso mehr
man das akzeptiert, umso mehr wird es das geben, das muss eigentlich jedem klar sein.
Und es ist ja wohl akzeptiert genug, sonst könnte man das nicht machen.
Und auch CD Projekt Red, die ja nur mit den Witcher Games und sowas sich einen schon ganz
guten Ruf aufgebaut haben, haben das halt mit einem Schlag und Cyberpunk versaut.
Cyberpunk, dass das in dieser Art und Weise rausgekommen ist, war auch eine reine Stonks
Geldentscheidung.
Mehrere Gründe dafür, die zum Teil sogar irgendwo nachvollziehbar und legitim sind.
Ein Grund ist, dass Corona natürlich die Spielentwicklung, die davor schon eine sehr
komplexe, komplizierte Aufgabe war, noch weiter erschwert hat, weil Firmen teils mitten in
der Entwicklung von den Spielen, die jetzt rausgekommen sind, wie zum Beispiel Battlefield
ins Homeoffice wechseln mussten und ihre komplette Führung und Kommunikationsstruppe.
Die hatten mega Probleme bei Battlefield in der Entwicklung, das haben wir ja auch in
dem Video letztens gesehen und das haben wir uns im Vorfeld ja auch schon gedacht.
Da haben aber aus meiner Sicht Projektmanager verkackt bei, erstens, die sind dafür da,
die bekommen dafür Geld, um solche Probleme zu lösen und wie gesagt, die Ansätze in
die Richtung, wie sich das entwickelt hat, die waren ja auch vor Corona alle schon da.
Ich meine, man denke mal an das letzte Star Wars Battlefront, das war vor Corona und
ich glaube, da kann sich noch jeder dran erinnern, Fallout 76 war auch vor Corona, also das ist
nichts, was durch Corona ausgelöst wurde.
Manchmal ist es vielleicht auch so, dass der Publisher entscheidet, obwohl der Entwickler
sogar sagen würde, Leute, wir brauchen noch mehr Zeit, wir müssen das weiter entwickeln,
aber der Publisher hat jahrelang schon Marketingpläne konzipiert, die sich nicht mehr so leicht
verschieben lassen.
Möglicherweise machen die Aktionäre Druck, die jetzt das Weihnachtsgeschäft mitnehmen
wollen, damit die Aktionäre Druck...
Normalerweise muss ich über Grafik-Clatches nicht lachen, weil ich habe da schon mehr
oder weniger alles gesehen und ich sehe meistens so einfach irgendwie Verbacken-Kram, aber
das finde ich tatsächlich doch witzig.
Oder möglicherweise geht halt auch schlichtweg das Geld aus und die Entwicklung kann nicht
fortgesetzt werden.
Das passiert bei großen Studios genau wie bei kleinen, es ist gar nicht so, dass das
nur die großen bösen Firmen wie EA sind, die dann eben z.B. ein Battlefield unfertig
raushauen.
Das passiert genauso bei Wolcen oder The Ascent, also eher kleineren Rollenspielen, die ebenfalls
in richtig blödem Zustand erschienen sind in den letzten Jahren und es scheint mir
eben schon so, dass bei allen Aspekten...
Sekunde!
...die da...
Spielt überhaupt noch jemand Wolcen, das hatten wir uns auch letztens, nee hatten wir
uns nicht, SteamStats, Wolcen, ich tippe mal auf 100 Spieler, 304, immerhin, von 127.000
Piek, nice, nice, sehr gut, sehr gut, exellent, ihr Wolcen, oh mann...
Ich sage gewissermaßen schon auch nachvollziehbar sind, weil Spielentwicklung ist auch ein
Geschäft und Geld ist nicht unbegrenzt, aber genau so beobachte ich da schon mehr und mehr,
dass Firmen auch für sich entschieden haben, wir brauchen gar nicht mehr unbedingt einen
guten Ruf bei unseren Fans, bei unseren Spielern um Geld...
Und du hast trotzdem, das ist ja das was mich immer so wahnsinnig anpisst, du hast trotzdem
immer noch die Hardcore-Fanboys, die das alles bis aufs Blut verteidigen, so als hättest
du ihre Mutter beleidigt, wenn du was über ihr Game sagst...
Und das sind die eigentlichen Leute, die richtig lost sind...
Und es gibt ein paar Vorfälle in den letzten Jahren, die das für mich besonders klar gemacht
haben, einer ist zum Beispiel die Konsolen-Version von Cyberpunk, wo man die PS4-Version sehr
klar festhalten muss, das kann kein Versehen gewesen sein, vor allem nicht, dass die Firmenspitze
noch kurz vor Release Äußerungen rausgehauen hat, wie das läuft überraschend gut, und
hinterher...
Ich sag nur, way ahead of schedule bei Battlefield...
...sagt hat, wir haben's released, weil wir ehrlich gedacht haben, wir schaffen's bis
zum Release noch, was, also eine von diesen beiden Aussagen kann ja nicht stimmen...
Ja, ergibt keinen Sinn, widerspricht sich...
Weil entweder habt ihr vor Release gedacht, es läuft überraschend gut, oder ihr habt
gedacht, Leute wir schaffen das bis zum Release noch, ihr könnt ja nicht beides gedacht
haben, entweder gab's noch was zu schaffen...
Doch, doch, die Entwickler haben wahrscheinlich gebetet, wir schaffen das zum Release noch,
und die Marketing-Stonks-Leute haben den Käufern irgendwelchen Dummschmus erzählt, dass sie
doch jetzt mal mehr Geld reinstecken...
Oder es war alles super, nie im Leben...
Kommt drauf an, wen du fragst wahrscheinlich...
...haben sie diese miserable Konsolen-Version veröffentlicht, das kann ich mir schlichtweg
nicht vorstellen, da wurde die Entscheidung getroffen, wir hauen das so raus, und wir
verheimlichen das vor der Community, das war nicht transparent, da war egal, dass man sich
über Jahre einen Ruf als einer der wenigen letzten Spieler und Community-freundlichen
Entwickler aufgebaut hat...
Da ging's ums Geld, hat man drauf geschissen, ja...
Und das sieht man auch bei anderen Firmen, Blizzard hat entschieden, nicht nur so rauszuhauen,
wie es erschienen ist, sondern vor allem, es danach einfach so zu lassen...
Blizzard, Blizzard hat jetzt eins der am schlechtesten bewerteten Metacritic-Spiele aller Zeiten
in seinen...
Äh, Phasix, ja, das ist halt im Business-Bereich so, das ist die Realität...
Das, was intern der wirkliche Zustand eines Produkts ist und das, was kommuniziert wird,
sind zwei verschiedene Paar Schuhe...
Es ist schade, dass es letztendlich so ist, weil gerade bei Spielen führt es dazu, dass
im Endeffekt alle enttäuscht sind, es kann mir ja auch keiner erzählen, dass es, sag
man mal, einen Entwickler bei DICE kalt lässt, ja...
Jemand, der quasi eineinhalb Jahre mindestens wirklich da auch sehr viel Energie in ein
Spiel reingesteckt hat, der liest sicherlich nicht gerne oder hört sicherlich nicht gerne,
dass alle da Spielkacke finden...
Garantiert nicht, also, das sind ja auch nur Menschen alles und in der Regel möchte man,
dass das, was man quasi unter viel Arbeitseinsatz gebaut hat, gut ankommt...
Also, die finden es sicherlich nicht geil...
...einem Portfolio als Teil der Firmengeschichte und das Blizzard-Management oder das Activision-Blizzard-Management,
wer auch immer das war, hat entschieden, das ist okay, es ist den Aufwand nicht wert, so
was zu fixen, wir lassen dieses schwarze Mal unserer Firmengeschichte jetzt einfach so
stehen.
Genau wie EA entschieden hat, ein Flop wie Anthem kann auch bei BioWare jetzt einfach
mal so stehen bleiben.
BioWare ebenfalls eine Marke mit früher mal unglaublicher Strahlkraft, wo sich der Publisher
und aktuelle Besitzer EA dann entschieden hat, passt schon, wenn da so ein Flop wie
Anthem mit dabei ist und das wäre doch früher unvorstellbar gewesen, dass bei Firmen wie
BioWare oder Blizzard oder CD Projekt solche Entscheidungen getroffen werden...
Ich werde nicht vergessen, das sind Leute, die Spiele wie Dragon Age 1 gemacht haben,
was meiner Meinung nach eines der, was mit Abstand das beste Dragon Age Game ist.
Das add-on mal außen vor, aber das Main Game Dragon Age Origins, das ist richtig gut...
...einfach sagt, ist doch egal, was die Leute sagen werden und ich will damit klarstellen,
ich bin absolut bewusst und das sollten auch sich Leute da draußen bewusst machen, die
diese Entscheidungen kritisieren.
Sind das überhaupt noch die gleichen Developer vom Namen her noch, von den Leuten, die da
sind?
Wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil nicht mehr.
Werden diese Entscheidungen nicht von den einzelnen Entwicklern getroffen, das sind
nicht die Grafiker, das sind nicht die Level Designer, das sind nicht die Quest Autoren,
die entscheiden, das ist klar, wir hauen das raus und fixen es hinterher nicht.
Das sind Leute über den Management, die mehr auf den Aktienkurs und die Poverentabilität
schauen, als darauf, was das Anständige, das Korrekte gegenüber der Community wäre und
manchmal ist es ja auch so...
Die interessieren sich ja auch einen Scheiß für die Community, das geht denen am Arsch
vorbei.
Meint ihr wirklich, es ist jemand, das kommt ja öfters vor, die stellen sich auf die Bühne
und sagen, wir möchten uns bei allen unseren Fans bedanken, wir haben die besten Fans,
die man sich wünschen kann, danke Leute, ihr seid die besten, sowas in der Richtung,
sagen die ja gerne auf irgendwelchen Veranstaltungen.
Meint ihr wirklich, irgendjemand, dieser Anzugtypen, der da vorne auf der Bühne steht, meint das
wirklich ernst, was er da sagt?
Das ist denen so scheißegal?
Zum Beispiel bei Cyberpunk gibt es ja Bemühungen absolut, das Spiel hinterher zu fixen, aber
dass allein die Entscheidung getroffen wurde, diese Konsolenversion, hauen wir erst mal
so raus.
Wieso bekommen die noch Geld?
Ich glaube, das ist einmal eine Mischung, es gibt jetzt halt mehrere Gründe, viele befinden
sich noch ein bisschen in der Phase der Realitätsverweigerung, viele Leute sagen jetzt, ich habe jetzt
Entwickler XY über Jahre die Treue gehalten und fand das immer gut, wenn ich jetzt sage,
das ist quasi nicht mehr gut, dann würde ich ja in Frage stellen, habe ich mein Leben
nicht verschwendet die letzten zehn Jahre, jetzt übertrieben gesagt, aber so Gedanken
hat man ja, es kommt ja öfters vor, dass man Sachen abstreitet, die eigentlich offensichtlich
sein müssten, weil man dann sich gleichermaßen eingesteht, man hat selbst quasi jahrelang
was gemacht, was eigentlich verschenkt war, das ist wie die Leute, die damals ernsthaft
darüber diskutiert haben, dass auf der PS3 PSN besser ist als Xbox Live, das haben die
einfach nur, die waren so getriggert, wenn man gesagt hat, Xbox Live ist besser, weil
sie sich dann quasi automatisch eingestehen mussten, sie haben vielleicht nicht das beste,
was es gibt und vielleicht haben sie sich für den falschen Kauf entschieden, also Xbox
Live verbessert PSN for free, zum Beispiel, gibt noch mehrere Punkte, übergreifende Partys
und was auch immer und dann hätten die sich ja eingestehen müssen, ey fuck, vielleicht
habe ich jetzt meine Oma zwei Jahre umsonst bearbeitet, dass die mir das Geld für eine
Playstation gibt, deswegen sind die Leute bei solchen Themen auch immer so emotional
ultra getriggert gleich, man gesteht sich unglaublich ungern ein, wenn man, falsch ist
noch nicht mal das richtige Wort, ich weiß nicht, wie ich es nennen soll, wenn man,
wie könnte man das nennen, wenn sich im Nachhinein Sachen halt als nicht so das herausstellen,
was man selbst geklaut hat die letzten Jahre über und wenn jetzt einer seit World of Warcraft
Release übelster Blizzard Fanboy ist und es ihm eigentlich schon mindestens die letzten
fünf Jahre über klar sein müsste, dass das alte Blizzard eigentlich nicht mehr da ist,
dann sagt er sich aber, hey, ich verschließe da lieber die Augen immer weiter davor, weil
mit jedem weiteren Tag müsste ich mir quasi einen längeren Zeitraum eingestehen, an dem
ich quasi an das falsche geklaut habe sozusagen und das machen die Leute nicht gern, ist ja
unverständlich, keiner macht da keiner gerne, so also das ist glaube ich ein Punkt, viele
befinden sich noch so in dieser Phase der Realitätsverweigerung, das ist dann so eine
Mischung aus Hardcore Fanboys und Leute, die es einfach nicht wahrhaben wollen, dann gibt
es ultra viele Casuals, die von der ganzen Sache gar nichts mitkriegen und sich halt
so mitreißen lassen, so nach dem Motto, hey, neues Battlefield, richtig krasse, geile Werbung,
guck ich mir mal an, was auch immer und es ist nicht zu unterschätzen, wie viele Casuals
es gibt, die Leute, die sich wirklich im Kern oder tiefer mit Games auseinandersetzen, ist
ja gerade wenn man guckt mal Richtung Mobile Gaming, komplett die Minderheit, kein Wunder,
dass Mobile Gaming so groß ist und das dritte ist, es gibt Leute wie mich, die es eigentlich
besser wissen und sich den Kram trotzdem kaufen, weil sie es nicht wahrhaben wollen,
ja gut, eigentlich bin ich auch, eigentlich bin ich auch, wenn du es so willst, eigentlich
kannst du mich auch zu Gruppe 1 zählen, mir war es eigentlich mehr oder weniger klar,
aber ich habe trotzdem gedacht, Alter, das könnt ihr doch nicht verkacken und was natürlich
auch noch dabei kommt, Leute sind träge, Leute sind faul, es dauert alles ein bisschen
und man kann das auch nicht nur quasi immer auf uns schieben im Endeffekt, die Hersteller
und die Herstellerinnen und Hersteller, die versuchen, das ja auch geschickt zu umgehen,
ja, ihr habt es bei der Marketing Geschichte von Battlefield 2042 gesehen, wie sehr da
auf die Gefühls-Schiene für alte Battlefield-Veteranen gesetzt wurden, vom Dock-Tech-Messern, bis
zum Jeep, der springt und das Flugzeug in die Luft springt, bis zum RPG aus dem Jet
und sowas in der Richtung, das hat mit dem fertigen Game nichts, aber auch wieder nichts
zu tun, das hat man gemacht, um die Veteranen emotional gezielt anzusprechen, weil sie
genau wussten, danach kriegen sie die Leute nicht mehr, die machen das schon geschickt,
das kommt ja auch noch dabei, so jetzt wollen wir das Video mal weiter gucken.
Wie hoch da die Meinung der Community gewichtet wurde, versus...
Stonks, endlich, Maurice, endlich fängt er auch mit dem passenden Meme dafür an, Stonks,
jawoll, bester Mann, PR-Pläne, Aktionäre, Weihnachtsgeschäft, derlei Geschichten und
was finde ich noch viel schwerer wiegt, wir sehen das genauso, also diese eine gewisse
Gleichgültigkeit gegenüber dem, was die Leute da draußen wohl sagen werden, bei noch
viel schlimmeren Skandalen, weil ein kaputtes Spiel ist ja eine Sache, gibt man 60 Euro
für ein Produkt, das dann vielleicht nicht so geil ist, ist nicht cool, sollte nicht
passieren, aber ist auch kein Weltuntergang, was kommt jetzt Diesel, Dieselabgas oder was
kommt jetzt als Beispiel, wie den jüngsten Skandalen um Activision Blizzard, woraus kam,
dass in dieser Firma systematisch über Jahre hinweg Frauen und andere Minderheiten aufs
übelste misshandelt wurden, merken wir jetzt, ich hab's ja am Anfang das Thema auch so
ein bisschen ignoriert, bis ich dann vor so zwei, drei Monaten auch ein bisschen mehr
zu dieser Thematik gelesen hab, Leute, es ist viel krasser diese ganze Geschichte, als
man eigentlich so denkt und eigentlich so mitbekommt, wenn man sich da die Berichte
zu durchliest, wie gesagt, es gab Berichte, es gab Artikel drüber über Frauen, die gesagt
haben, ihre Führungskraft hat sie und die wollten sogar vor Gericht gehen, ihre Führungskraft
hat sie vergewaltigt oder auf Firmenfeiern quasi abgefüllt, um sie danach zu vergewaltigen
und sowas, das ist ultra krass, was da abgelaufen ist, das ist wirklich absolut hardcore und
was hat Bobby unter anderem gemacht oder wofür wurde unter anderem gesorgt, dass man sich
außergerichtlich geeinigt hat, dass das nicht irgendwie an die Öffentlichkeit kommt und
sowas wurde dann gemacht, wo man normalerweise ja mal zumindest irgendwelche Entscheidungsorgane
von Aufsichtsrat bis Directors Board und was es da nicht alles gibt informieren muss,
haben die einfach mal nicht informiert, was da abgeht ist richtig heftig, also das hab
ich am Anfang selbst nicht so ganz gerafft, aber wenn man sich das mal ein bisschen zu
durchlegt, das ist wirklich krass, was da abgegangen ist, die Firma kann sich nicht mal aufraffen,
die aller einfachsten PR Alibi Maßnahmen zu ergreifen, um irgendwie zu versuchen ihren
Ruf zu reparieren, zum Beispiel bei Activision Blizzard, die haben danach gesagt, okay wir
ernennen jetzt bei Blizzard, achja das beste, das beste habe ich ja zu dem Thema, es hat
doch bei Blizzard angeblich die, was war das, Head of, die eine, die sie da hatten für
Diversity Fragen und sonst was, die hat ja eine Mail geschrieben, intern an die Blizzard
Mitarbeiter, also für Harassment und Diversity Fragen und sonst was, da hatten sie, ich weiß
nicht, wie die hieß, zumindest hatten sie da eine und die hat eine Mail geschrieben intern
an die Blizzard Mitarbeiter, wie stolz sie eigentlich drauf ist, dass sie bei so einer
tollen Firma arbeitet und wisst ihr, was dann im Nachhinein rausgekommen ist, die Mail hat
sie gar nicht selbst geschrieben, dreimal dürft ihr raten, wer diese Mail in ihrem Namen
geschrieben hat, der könne es nur gewesen sein und das hat er sogar zugegeben, das hat
er sogar zugegeben, alter, was ein Upclusterfuck, was, ja gut, die Aktionen die Blizzard da
macht sind ja eh komplett Tropfen auf einem heißen Stein, das ist wie das McCree in Overwatch
umbenannt wird, das sind alles Aktionen, die Blizzard macht, in der Hoffnung sie stehen
dann besser da, das ändert aber ja nicht die interne, so, Gesinnung der, oder so, das interne,
den internen Antrieb der Leute, die dort in Führungsposition sind, wenn McCree jetzt
umbenannt wird, ja, das ändert nicht die Kultur in der Firma, wenn McCree jetzt nicht
mal McCree heißt, das sind sicherlich Sachen, die man machen kann, wo man auch sagen kann,
ja, das ist gerechtfertigt, ok, aber das ändert ja nichts an der eigentlichen Problematik,
das sind einfach nur Versuche von Blizzard, das jetzt irgendwie mit billigen Maßnahmen
da rauszukommen, McCree wurde umbenannt, ja, weil McCree nach einem ehemaligen Mitarbeiter,
glaube ich bin mir da, ich bin 100% nicht sicher ob ich das richtig erzähle, nach einem
ehemaligen Mitarbeiter mit benannt war, der in diesem ganzen Skandal mit verstrickt ist,
natürlich kann man McCree umbenennen, aber das ändert nicht die Kultur in dieser Firma,
das sorgt einfach nur dafür, dass man sagen kann, hey, Presse, guckt mal hier, wir machen
da was, uns ist das jetzt super wichtig, dass das hier bei uns alles super läuft, wenn es
euch super wichtig wäre, das erste was ihr hätten machen müssen ist Bobby rausschmeißen
und wahrscheinlich 90% der anderen Führungsriege, aber das geht ja nicht, weil Stonks, ein Führungsduo
aus einem Mann und einer Frau, um irgendwie zu zeigen, Leute, ab jetzt wollen wir hier
einen Kurs für mehr Gleichberechtigung fahren und nur ein paar Monate später kam raus,
die Firma hat sich aktiv geweigert, der Frau Jen O'Neill das gleiche Gehalt für den gleichen
Job zu zahlen wie dem Mann Mike Ibarra, obwohl beide, auch der Mann das mehrfach gefordert
haben und das zeigt doch, diese Firma ist nicht mal bereit, die aller simpelsten Maßnahmen
zu ergreifen, um irgendwie zumindest so auszusehen, als würden sie sich drum scheren um diesen
Skandal.
Dafür haben sie doch jetzt McCree umbenannt, Mensch, jetzt muss doch aber auch mal gut
sein, McCree umbenannt und fertig.
Es ist einfach komplett egal, Activision Blizzard hat alles Geld der Welt, die können wir doch
nie im Leben sagen, dass es ein großes Problem für sie gewesen wäre, den beiden Blizzard-Chefs,
also auch einem der wichtigsten Posten in der ganzen Firma, das gleiche Gehalt zu zahlen.
Oh, da ist er.
Wie absurd diese Entscheidung ist und ich finde, wenn man all diese Dinge zusammennimmt,
die verschiedensten kaputten Releases über die letzten Jahre, von Anthem bis Battlefield,
die ganzen Skandale, wo wirklich man immer wieder den Eindruck hat, es werden eigentlich
nur so mäßig öffentlichkeitswirksame Alibi-Maßnahmen ergriffen, statt wirklich grundlegend was
zu ändern.
Das ist von Gamestyle.
Das zeigt für mich halt, es gibt ein großes Kontingent von Entscheidungsträgern in der
Gaming-Branche und wie gesagt, das ist nicht der kleine Entwickler an der Front, das sind
die Entscheidungsträger.
Das sage ich ja auch öfters dabei, wenn ich mich über solche Sachen aufrege, das sage
ich ja öfters dabei, hey, ich weiß, dass die meisten Entwickler dafür nichts können.
Ich denke, das muss man auch der Fans halber dabei sagen, weil ich habe eben gerade vor
10 Minuten schon mal gesagt, die sind damit ja auch nicht glücklich.
Niemand wird gerne geflamed für ein Spiel, wo er trotzdem eineinhalb, zwei Jahre hart
für gearbeitet hat und was aus Gründen scheiße geworden ist, wo der normale Entwickler oder
Level-Designer oder Artist absolut keinerlei Einfluss drauf hat.
Die entschieden haben, es ist doch eigentlich auch gar nicht so wichtig, ob sich da ein
paar Leute im Internet aufregen, das ist doch für unsere Geschäftsergebnisse letztlich
egal.
Die Frage ist...
Naja, Phloxig, ich denke, gerade wenn man sich mal den Fall anguckt von Battlefield
2042, ich glaube, man kann das gar nicht so sehr 100% dem einen oder 100% dem anderen
zuschustern.
Ich denke mal, bei einem Fall von Battlefield 2042 sind es zwei maßgebliche Sachen.
DICE hat keinen Plan mehr, was sie machen, unabhängig von dieser Corona Homeoffice-Geschichte
oder so, die sicherlich auch Probleme gemacht hat.
Nexy, danke für den Sub.
DICE hat es verkackt.
Okay, das ist Punkt Nummer eins.
EA hat es aber insoweit verkackt, dass man eben gesagt hat, okay, jetzt ist es auch egal,
wir müssen das zum Weihnachtsgeschäft 2021 raushauen.
Also, dass quasi am Ende die Entscheidung gefällt wurde, oder was heißt am Ende, ja
vorher, die Entscheidung gefällt wurde hier, hier ist Deadline.
Also, die haben damit bestimmt nicht dazu beigetragen.
Es waren zwei Sachen.
DICE hat es sicherlich mit verkackt, weil das Spiel hat ja in Ansätzen schon designtechnisch
so große Probleme, das kannst du nicht alles auf EA und mangelnde Zeit schieben.
Das sind so ganz grundlegende Entscheidungen dabei.
Da muss ich mal den Aufbau der Maps angucken und sowas.
Aber dass es dann wirklich released werden musste in diesem Zustand, das ist wiederum
die EA-Geschichte.
RolloW, oder RolloWL, danke für den Sub.
Stimmt das?
Ist es wirklich eine schlaue Strategie?
Und es gibt glaube ich ein paar Dinge, die tatsächlich dafür sprechen, es ist so.
Und der erste und wahrscheinlich auch wichtigste in der Kalkulation ist, weniger Leute kriegen
diese Skandale überhaupt mit, als wir denken.
Wir, die wir sehr eingefangen haben.
Da hat der Follower ganz recht, die 0815casualmobile-gamer, die juckt das nicht, die interessiert das
nicht, die kriegen davon auch nichts mit.
Ja und die Reddit-Empörten und Twitter-Empörten und sonst was, das ist halt nun mal die Minderheit.
Vielleicht die Gaming-Branche verfolgen, wenn ihr dieses Video schaut, dann seid ihr Teil
der Zielgruppe, für die Gaming interessiert, die sich intensiv genug mit Gaming beschäftigen,
dass ihr euch regelmäßig YouTube-Videos, Meinungs-Videos dazu anschaut.
Das macht euch ja schon zu Ausnahmepublikum verglichen mit der breiteren Gaming-Masse.
Und Leute, wir sind massive big brain.
Wenn es gut läuft, nimm mal an, werden es so 200.000 Leute sehen und statistisch gesehen
gucken sich diese Leute im Schnitt die Hälfte des Videos an.
Die Konsolen-Versionen, also die schlechten Konsolen-Versionen von CyberHunt.
Ja, Baumhaus-Panzer, das kann durchaus passieren, dass das langfristig keine gute Idee ist,
aber es war bei der Bahn, somit mal ein Beispiel außerhalb der Gaming-Branche zu nehmen, es
war bei der Bahn auch abzusehen, dass es langfristig keine gute Strategie ist, Strecken abzubauen,
obwohl man eigentlich mehr gebraucht hätte.
Man hat es aber für kurzfristige Stonks, Geld und Gewinn trotzdem gemacht.
So kann das hier genauso laufen.
Für PS4 und Xbox One haben sich im ersten Monat über 7 Millionen mal verkauft.
Da ist es doch tatsächlich irgendwo sogar nachvollziehbar, wenn ein Entscheidungsträger
irgendwo sagt, wenn sich ein paar YouTuber darüber aufregen, wie viele Leute kriegen
das ernsthaft mit, versus wie viele Leute keine Ahnung haben.
Wer kriegt das ernsthaft mit und zieht da raus, das sind ja noch viel weniger, zieht
da raus ernsthaft Konsequenzen.
Es kriegen schon nicht viele mit und die, die es mitkriegen, ziehen da wahrscheinlich
auch nicht wirklich Konsequenzen raus.
Und dann werden halt solche Entscheidungen getroffen.
FIFA zum Beispiel, jährlich irgendwelche Skandale, ist es zu pay to win, ist Ultimate
Team doof, ist die PC-Version schon wieder eine peinliche Enttäuschung, aber es ist
eine pure Gelddruckmaschine für EA.
Völlig egal, wie viele Leute sich unmeidlich darüber aufliegen.
Das ist mir auch absolut ein Ding, es gibt kaum etwas, was für mich so unverständlich
ist wie FIFA-Spieler.
Ich kann es nicht nachvollziehen, wie man jedes Jahr quasi wieder bei Null anfangen kann
und weiter quasi in irgendwelche Glücksspiel-Surprise-Mechanics investiert.
Das kann doch eigentlich nur damit erklärt werden, dass es irgendwelche Glückshormone
ausschüttet, wenn man goldene Packages zieht, oder?
Was anderes kann es doch eigentlich gar nicht sein.
Was anderes kann ich mir nicht darunter vorstellen, das ist mir komplett unbegreiflich.
Weil es ein viel größeres Publikum gibt, ich kritisiere dieses Publikum gar nicht.
Ich sage ja gar nicht, jeder Gamer sollte sich täglich YouTube-Videos über all die
Skandale der Branche anschauen.
Ich habe genauso Hobbys, die ich vielmehr hobbymäßig verfolge.
Ich gucke mir auch nicht täglich YouTube-Videos zu Netflix-Serien und Kinofilmen an, weil
das für mich mehr ein Hobby ist, als ich so nebenbei habe, aber ich habe keine Ahnung
über die verschiedensten Produktionsbedingungen bei jeder Netflix-Serie, die ich schaue zum
Beispiel, weil das wiederum für mich was ist, wo ich sage, ich habe nicht die Zeit,
wie alle Hobbys, die ich habe, so intensiv zu beschäftigen und genauso ist das halt
beim Gaming.
Es gibt so viele Leute, die diese ganzen Skandale gar nicht mitkriegen und selbst von denen,
die sie mitkriegen, seien wir ehrlich, GTA 6 wird sich verkaufen wie geschnitten Brot,
egal wie viele Leute jetzt sagen, wow, diese Neuauflagen von den alten GTAs waren aber
echt eine Katastrophe.
Das ist glaube ich wirklich...
Und jedes Mal, wisst ihr was ich auch witzig finde, jedes Mal wird dann vor dem Release
des Spiels gesagt, so nach dem Motto, jetzt hat der Hersteller endlich verstanden, was
die Fans wollen.
Ah, doch nicht, aber jetzt hat der Hersteller endlich verstanden, was die Fans wollen.
Ah, wieder doch nicht, aber dieses Mal, dieses Mal hat der Hersteller wirklich verstanden,
was die Fans wirklich wollen.
Das ist ja auch ein Phänomen, was man an allen Ecken und Enden beobachten kann.
Letztlich egal, das wird nicht so viele Leute davon abbringen, sich das nächste GTA zu
kaufen.
Nö, das wird sich verkaufen wie Sau.
Weil sie halt GTA-Fans sind, weil sie Bock drauf haben, weil ihnen diese Neuauflagen
vielleicht gar nicht so richtig sind.
Und ich sage auch gar nicht, dass man sich immer um alles so scheren muss, ich versuche
hier nur...
Ich glaube es gibt eben ein sehr großes Publikum, das da einfach sagen wird, ist doch jetzt
auch gar nicht so wichtig.
Ja, ja, das ist so.
Und es gibt sogar noch...
Das bin ich nicht.
Das ist ein Video von der GameStar, was wir uns hier angucken.
Noch mehr, es gibt auch Leute, die aktiv mir zum Beispiel als Feedback geben, Junge, reg
dich doch nicht so auf.
Ja, das habe ich lustigerweise unter meinen Videos auch und ja, ich kann das sogar verstehen.
Es gibt Leute, die sagen, Max, guck mal, du bist jetzt 37, was regst du dich dann über
irgendwie ein schlechtes Game-Release auf?
Und dann muss ich sagen, eigentlich haben die Leute recht, aber auf der anderen Seite
ist es halt nur mal ein Thema, was mich interessiert und weil es ein Thema ist, was mich interessiert
und auch irgendwie so ein bisschen emotional mitnimmt, ist das auch was, worüber ich mich
eben aufrege.
Du kannst immer...
Du kannst zu allem irgendwie sagen, was nicht essenziell fürs Überleben ist, ach, was regst
dich da drüber so auf, ist doch nicht so wild.
Ja.
Aber ich meine, wir vegetieren halt nun mal nicht nur vor uns hin, wir interessieren uns
für andere Sachen als für, äh, wie kriege ich genug Essen und wo kann ich im warmen
schlafen.
Die Probleme haben wir ja glücklicherweise nicht mehr.
Zum Glück haben wir die hier nicht.
Und das ist halt das Thema, wofür ich mich interessiere, aber das habe ich unter meinen
Videos auch.
Ich habe versucht in meiner Berichterstattung zu Diablo 2, wo ich konnte, auch auf die aktuellen
Bedingungen bei Blizzard hinzuweisen.
Es gab einerseits Leute, die gesagt haben, finde ich gut, dass du das machst, da sollte
man drüber reden.
Ich habe aber auch jedes Mal Kommentare bekommen, die gesagt haben, jetzt kommt der schon wieder
damit an, wir wissen es doch inzwischen, halt doch mal die Klappe, ich will doch nicht
jedes Mal daran erinnert werden, ich will doch einfach nur das Spiel genießen und zocken.
Das gibt es genauso und auf solche Leute setzen, glaube ich, diese großen Firmen, wenn sie
sagen, wenn wir es einfach machen und totschweigen und vielleicht klappt ja auch gut für uns.
Klappt ja oft genug.
Ich glaube aber auch ganz persönlich, es ist vielleicht ganz langfristig gedacht, auch
nicht ganz zu Ende gedacht, diese Strategie, weil man sieht.
Auf die Idee ist ja der Chat eben auch schon gekommen, dass das langfristig nicht unbedingt
aufgehen muss.
Schon auch, wie es sich negativ auf verschiedenste Entwickler auswirkt, die diese Entscheidung
getroffen haben.
Wenn sie Spiele in einem offensichtlich kaputten Zustand releasen, dann erschwert das zumindest
einen wichtigen Aspekt der Spieleentwicklung, nämlich die engagierten Fans weiter zu monetarisieren
in der DLCs und Mikrotestationen zu verkaufen, weil dafür brauchst du schon eine Kernzielgruppe
von glücklichen Fans, die bei der Stange bleiben, die das Spiel weiter spielen.
Ja, exakt.
Das hatte ich ja auch letztens, du brauchst, wer ist das, die letztendlich, also erstens
die Spieler zu dem gemacht haben, was sie heute sind und wer ist das, wenn die Spiele
langfristig spielen wird?
Das wird eine Gruppe aus Hardcore-Fans sein, deswegen sage ich ja auch, du brauchst in
den, sagen wir mal jetzt in irgendwelchen MMOs oder sowas, du brauchst dort auch Content
für eben diese Zielgruppe.
Du brauchst Content, der sich eben an absolute High-End-Leute richtet.
Content, den normale 0815 Casual Gamer nie spielen würde.
Erstens, dass du was hast, worauf du hinarbeiten kannst, aber auch, dass du deine Hardcore-Fanbase,
die in den 15 Jahren Abo ohne Unterbrechung laufen lassen haben, dass du die letztendlich
irgendwie zufriedenstellst, weil in schweren Zeiten sind das auch die, die letztendlich
dein Game am Leben halten.
Das gilt für Multiplayer, das beim Beispiel gilt für Multiplayer-Games.
Ich denke mal, das ist bei Singleplayer-Games gar nicht so viel unterschiedlich.
Du hast da auch bei manchen Spiele-Serien jetzt halt so die Hardcore-Fanbase.
Guckt euch Dark Souls an, hat auch sehr viele Fans und sicherlich auch fannigere Fans als
andere.
Es gibt da super viele Big-Brain-Leute, die heute noch irgendwelche Dark Souls-Videos machen,
obwohl das Spiel auch schon eigentlich uralt ist, jetzt mal bis auf das Remake, die irgendwelche
Dark Souls-Videos machen, so nach dem Motto, so sieht die Spawn-Animation von Gegner XY
von hinten aus und sowas in der Richtung.
Das gucken sich teilweise 150.000 Leute an.
Also das sind Leute, die die Games langfristig am Leben halten.
Wir sehen das bei Marvel's Avengers, die hatten einen riesigen Plan für zehn Jahre Service-Game,
der offensichtlich jetzt nicht wirklich aufzugehen scheint, weil man nicht genügend Fans binden
konnte.
Und man sieht es auch z.B. bei Cyberpunk, dass wenn Cyberpunk in der gleichen Geschwindigkeit
DLCs erhalten hätte wie The Witcher 3, dann wäre da schon eine Erweiterung wie Blood & Wine
in den Startlöchern.
Eines der besten, also nicht nur die beste Witcher-Erweiterung, selbst wenn man nur Blood
& Wine für sich nimmt, finde ich es eines der besten Rollenspiele, die es gibt.
Ein riesiges Addon, eins der besten Addons, dass ich je für ein Spiel gespielt habe.
Muss man sich auf der Zunge ziehen.
Ich muss sagen, deswegen gucke ich wahrscheinlich Maurice gerne, der sieht viele Sachen, wahrscheinlich
gucke ich mir deswegen gerne an, weil er viele Sachen so sieht, wie ich sie aussehe.
An dem Punkt, wo jetzt Cyberpunk ist, war The Witcher 3 schon so weit, dass es ein Addon
wie Blood & Wine erhalten konnte.
Cyberpunk ist immer noch damit beschäftigt, Probleme vom Release zu fixen und muss alle
DLCs verschieben, was ja auch sich auf die Firmeneinnahmen natürlich niederschlägt,
weil Bug-Fix-Patches bringen kein Geld, also ein wenig schaden sich Firmen schon damit
und man sieht es auch, dass verschiedenste Firmen, die verschiedenste Skandale in den
letzten Jahren hatten, doch auch in ihrem Aktienkurs darunter gelitten haben.
Maurice sollte mal ein Video machen zu seinem Fitnessprogramm.
Der Typ hat so krass abgenommen, müsst euch mal die Videos angucken vor, keine Ahnung,
drei Jahren oder so.
Da war er so ungefähr so ein bisschen pepofett in meine Richtung und heute hat er hier die
halbe Boss-Transformation hinter sich.
Auch in ihrem Aktienkurs darunter gelitten haben CD Projekt, Ubisoft und Activision Blizzard.
Bei allen dreien ist der Aktienkurs in den letzten zwölf Monaten relativ kontinuierlich
gefallen oder stagniert, statt hochzugehen.
Und vielleicht zeigt das schon, dass man auch aus schlauer Firmen-Sicht vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr darauf achten sollte, was man dem Kunden zumutet.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, ist die Frage was überwiegt, man hat bei der Bahn auch Strecken abgebaut,
obwohl man wusste, dass das langfristig nicht sinnvoll ist.
Wenn man nur auf kurzfristiges, wenn man sich von Quartalsergebnis zu Quartalsergebnis
hangelt, dann interessieren so langfristige Sachen nicht.
Dann interessieren so langfristige Sachen erst, wenn es spürbar nach unten geht und
dann stellt man wahrscheinlich einen neuen Geschäftsführer ein oder so, der einem dann
das Blaue vom Himmel runter verspricht, wie sehr er in den Laden rumreißen wird.
Und das erste, was dann passiert, und das ist immer das Bittere daran ist, dass erstmal
40 Prozent der Entwickler entlassen wurden, die nichts anderes gemacht haben, als ihre
komplette Energie die letzten Jahre in das Produkt zu stecken.
Da trifft es immer erstmal komplett die Falschen.
Und wie transparent man damit ist und ob man nicht vielleicht eher besser beraten wäre,
dann mal die Aktionäre zu überzeugen, Leute, wir müssen das Spiel nochmal um ein Jahr
verschieben und ihr wisst sowieso, liebe Aktionäre, wenn wir Cyberpunk ein Jahr später
rausbringen mit einer funktionierenden Last-Gen-Konsolenversion, wird es sich ja trotzdem super verkaufen.
Und ich würde hoffen, dass diese Lektion vielleicht langfristig mal gelernt wird, aber
wenn man sich die Gaming-Branche als Ganzes anschaut, glaube ich, da sind die Anlagen
dafür gar nicht vorhanden.
Ich habe den Eindruck, viele Firmen, viele Entscheidungsträger haben für sich beschlossen,
wir probieren jetzt erstmal diesen Kurs, im Zweifelsfall lieber releasen und lieber todschweigen
und hinterher die Probleme lösen, als zu versuchen sie im Vorfeld zu vermeiden.
Und ich glaube deswegen, dass wir uns darauf einstellen müssen, dass uns Sachen wie die
Konsolenversion von Cyberpunk, wie die Releases von Battlefield und der GTA Trilogy und Anthem
und das ist sicherlich nicht die Ausnahme, Fallout 76, was auch immer es noch alles gab,
das ist schon in die Hose gegangen, auch vor Corona und wird auch weiterhin in die Hose
gehen.
Das will ich auch nochmal ganz klar sagen, ich will diese Skandale nicht gleichstellen
in diesem Video, also kaputte Spiele und Misshandlung von Mitarbeitern.
Ja, das muss man immer besonders ausführlich betonen, ganz ehrlich, ich hätte das Maurice
so auch nie unterstellt, aber es sind Leute immer richtig krass getriggert, im Zweifelsfall
muss man immer nochmal Disclaimer anbringen.
Das sind Skandalen auf unterschiedlichem Niveau, was eben nur für mich eine gewisse
...
Wer gar nicht auf die Idee gekommen ist, dass man sich daran stören könnte.
... eine gewisse Gleichgültigkeit der Firmenchefs über die Empörung darüber, also abseits
von PR Statements, aber auch diese deutlich schlimmeren Dinge, glaube ich, dass wir uns
darauf einstellen müssen, da wird noch mehr ans Licht kommen.
Mit Sicherheit.
Da wird...
Guck mal, was bei Ubisoft abgeht.
Nicht immer, zumindest ernsthafte Bestrebungen folgen, da wirklich Besserung zu tun und deswegen
glaube ich, das Spielejahr 2022 wird nochmal eher schlimmer als besser werden.
Wie seht ihr das?
Wie fandet ihr das Jahr 2021?
Ich würde Ihnen da im Großen und Ganzen schon zustimmen.
Einen Wendepunkt.
Ups.
Ja, da wollte ich jetzt gar nicht draufklinken, aber okay, okay.
Heute waren ja auch einige Leute von meinem Video getriggert, weil ich am Anfang einen
christlichen Systemadministrator-Job gezeigt habe.
Da haben auch welche gesagt hier, ich finde das nicht gut, dass du dich so lustig machst
über christliche Sachen.
Was ja auch ihr Recht ist, ja, können sich ja darüber beschweren.
Was aber nicht heißt, dass ich was anderes sage im Video.
Preige, genau, Preige.
Leute, schon spät.
Schon spät.
Ich sehs grade.
Uma, Bettge.
Müde.
Okay Leute, wir sehen uns, wahrscheinlich direkt morgen wieder, denke ich mal, dann
machen wir vielleicht ein bisschen Technik-Krams.
Also bis denn, machts gut, see you.